Ja, es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die ich in letzter Zeit gar nicht so mitbekommen habe.
Und ich meine, bei mir war in letzter Zeit sehr viel Arbeit.
Ich hätte dann, das ist so quasi akronomisierbar Sommerloch.
So ein bisschen.
Ja, ich meine, durch Corona haben wir eh ein Sommerloch für alles jetzt bekommen.
Bzw. Frühlings-Sommerloch.
Geht das eigentlich mit der Entfernung hier vom Mikro?
Das klingt gut.
Also ich finde es auch vor allem auch gut, dass du jetzt, deswegen habe ich dich auch ein bisschen weiter weggesetzt.
Damit wir nicht mehr beide so reden die ganze Zeit und in dieses Mikrofon reinflüstern.
Das ist ja kein ASMR-Podcast, wo wir ja sagen.
Leider.
Hallo, liebe Zuhörer.
Hallo, Hendrik.
Oh, hallo, Kilian. Wie geht's dir?
Das hört man gar nicht, oder?
So.
Ja, hi, Kilian.
Hey, Hendrik.
So, wir machen, ich glaube, die einzige In-Person-Folge dieses Jahr,
akronomisierbar, Folge 43.
43, ja stimmt, 43, krass.
43, genau.
Du sitzt tatsächlich mal bei mir, die letzten Male haben wir es immer remote gemacht.
Remote, genau.
Jetzt ist es auch ein bisschen remote, wir machen hier Social Distancing,
ich beschreibe mal das Setup, ich habe einen noch einen kleineren Tisch,
so ein bisschen weg von meinem Schreibtisch hingestellt,
du hast also deinen eigenen Tisch hier.
Das ist voll toll, also es ist eigentlich der Tisch, an dem wir immer zusammensaßen,
in der guten alten Pre-Pandemie-Zeit.
Genau.
Aber es ist voll witzig, weil so ein bisschen so ein Studio-Feeling
hier ist gerade. Du als Moderator,
als Radiomoderator da am Pult
und nicht so ein Extra-Titel.
Du bist der Gast-Experte. Das wird voll cool.
Genau. Und wir probieren
jetzt einfach mal so dieses Sommer
noch ein bisschen zu füllen und wir machen jetzt
akronomisierbar das Sommerspezial.
Was ist denn unser Sommerspezial?
Was passiert denn da? Weiß nicht, also zur Zeit passiert
irgendwie, dass alle aus dem Urlaub so eine
gehörige Portion Corona wieder mit nach Deutschland bringen.
Wo ich das ja für ein Gerücht halte, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist so, alle sagen, ach, die
Die Leute gehen in Urlaub und dann kommen sie alle mit Corona zurück.
Aber ich glaube, die Leute werden einfach unvorsichtig, oder?
Ja, eben. Ich glaube, das ist weniger, dass im Urlaubsland gibt es Corona,
es sei denn, du fährst nach Bayern oder so.
Aber das ist ja eher das Problem, dass du dich mit ein haufenweise Leuten zusammensetzt
und Urlaubslocations halt nicht darauf ausgelegt sind,
dass du da groß Distancing machst.
Die Leute haben irgendwie vergessen, Social Distancing und Aufpassen,
das ist so Arbeit und im Urlaub möchte ich da mir keine Sorgen drum machen.
Genau, du gehst mit den anderen Leuten, wenn du so richtig clever bist,
dann hättest du dich irgendwo an den Pool mit ein Haufen weißen
anderen Leuten zusammen und dann hast du halt genau
dasselbe, wenn du das hier machen würdest.
Witzigerweise, habe ich
vorhin gerade gelesen, hat ja in Neuseeland,
die ja wirklich bisher seit 100 Tagen
glaube ich gar keinen einzigen Fall hatten, weil die
verstanden haben, wie man mit so einer Krise umgeht.
Weil sie auch eine Insel sind.
Ja, und eine Insel sind quasi, wenn ihr mal früher
das Spiel Pandemic gespielt habt, die sind quasi
das in Madagaskar, wo, wenn man nicht
das Glück hatte, in diesem Spiel anzufangen,
auf Madagaskar, also in dem Spiel geht es darum, dass man
ist ein Virus oder Bakterium.
Gibt es da schon eine Corona-Version?
Auch 100 pro. Aber ich bin mir
gegenseitig, dass du möglichst viele Leute infizierst
und bestimmt auch umbringst. Bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Aber ich glaube, die Todeszahlen waren auch das jetzt schief und am Ende.
Und egal,
was du gemacht hast. Also meine Taktik war immer ein Virus,
weil die sind infektiöser als andere Sachen
gewesen. Was gäbe es noch
Alternativ dazu? Du konntest, ich glaube, ein Bakterium
sein. Also irgendwas tatsächlich
Lebendiges oder ein Parasit oder so.
Aber Viren waren am infektiösten.
Und meine Taktik war immer,
am Anfang erstmal alle meine Symptome verkaufen.
Also du musst dir für so Punkte kaufen,
du kannst aber auch verkaufen.
Und nachdem ich alle meine Symptome verkauft habe
und quasi nichts gemacht habe,
habe ich versucht, die ganze Welt zu infizieren,
ohne irgendwas zu machen.
Und dann habe ich mir auf einen Schlag einfach,
was total logisch auch ist,
bin ich global gleichzeitig mutiert mit dem Symptom tot.
Ja, genau.
Also wenn du Symptome hast, fällst du ja auf.
Das war immer so meine Taktik.
Aber der Präsident von Madagaskar hat halt instinkt,
sobald irgendwas war, alle Grenzen geschlossen.
Und die hatten nur einen Hafen oder so.
da kam da nichts mehr rein und diese Insel hat immer
überlebt, wenn du nicht gerade mal da ganz gerade startest.
Nicht schlecht.
Naja, aber im Endeffekt ist das genauso, wie
Corona funktioniert. Das ist ansteckend,
bevor du Symptome hast. Deswegen
musst du einfach aufpassen, selbst
wenn du sagst, wir können uns ja irgendwie zusammen
mal eine Stunde in den Faschel stellen oder sowas,
kein Problem.
Ja, tolle Freizeitbeschäftigung.
Bei mir geht es gut und dir geht es gut und am
nächsten Tag hustet einer von beiden und dann denkst du dir so,
fuck, jetzt habe ich es auch. Ja, auf der anderen Seite gibt es
halt auch zu mir viele Leute, bei denen es halt komplett ohne Symptome
verläuft, also die komplett asymptomatisch sind und trotzdem
die Krankheit weiter verteilen.
Und das ist halt gerade immer das Gefährliche.
Zum einen, das, was du meinst, man ist schon infektiös,
bevor man es überhaupt weiß. Und das andere ist,
man kriegt es halt generell nie mit. Und man verteilt
es einfach weiter. Man wird schon passen, ich merke ja nichts.
Genau, genau. Aber
dann ist man zumindest, glaube ich, trotzdem
nach zwei Wochen nicht mehr infektiös.
Ich glaube, das ist generell der Verlauf, aber wahrscheinlich
gibt es da auch hier plus minus sonst was
für Abweichung. So, das war also
unsere Kategorie
Corona-Update.
Achso, Neuseeland wollte ich noch kurz sagen.
Die hatten ja gar keine Fälle mehr, aber die haben jetzt wieder Fälle gehabt
und haben da halt mal Diagnose drauf geworfen und geschaut, wo kommen die her.
Und es waren gleich ein paar Infektionen, die sie hatten.
Alles aus England.
Die kommen alle von Leuten, die mit gefrorenem Fleisch zu tun hatten.
Also tatsächlich gibt es jetzt gerade die Theorie brandneu,
dass sich wohl Corona auch möglicherweise einfrieren lässt
und über solche importiertes Hühnchenfleisch oder so möglicherweise mit sich verteilt.
Was natürlich gerne mal ein bisschen spaßiger damit gleich wird.
Naja, es ist jetzt die richtige Zeit, um vegan zu werden, würde ich sagen.
Dafür ist es immer die richtige Zeit.
Es ist immer die richtige Zeit, um vegan zu werden.
Ansonsten ist es gerade pottwarm.
Es tut mir fast so ein bisschen leid, dass ich dich in meine Wohnung eingeladen habe,
weil bei dir wäre es wahrscheinlich kühler gewesen.
Ja, aber es ist immer noch angenehmer als draußen gerade gewesen
und die fünf Minuten zwischen uns waren genug,
dass es wieder unangenehm draußen war.
Jetzt wird es auch gerade richtig schwül.
Oft sieht es so ein bisschen aus, ob es noch regnet,
aber ein bisschen soll ja noch gewittert werden.
Mein Hitze-Hack ist, dass ich mir an den heißen Tagen
gerne einfach mal die Badewanne mit kaltem Wasser voll habe.
Hast du mich auf Twitter gesehen?
Einfach mal Füße ins kalte Wasser halten.
Kaffee in der Hand.
Ich bin letztes Wochen noch rumgegangen durch die Stadt
und dann habe ich mal die Füße hier ins Wasser gehalten,
die Füße da ins Wasser gehalten.
An einem Abend, wo es richtig schlimm war,
habe ich tatsächlich richtig ein kaltes Bad genommen.
Das ist auch angenehm. Das braucht so ein bisschen
Überwindung.
Aber wenn du dich einmal dann reinfallen
lässt, dann ist das, glaube ich, super angenehm.
Ich habe hier so eine Dachwohnung, die wird einfach unangenehm warm.
Aber eine schöne Sache, die ich gelesen
habe, es ist tatsächlich der kälteste Sommer
dieses Jahrhundert. Bitte was?
Der kälteste Sommer der nächsten 50 Jahre.
Ach so, ja, okay. Ich meine,
gut, wenn du so reingehst, dann ist es
wow.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das Jahr mit der wenigsten
Pandemieprobleme in den nächsten
50 Jahren.
Meinst du, das wird einfach immer weiter.
Das ist die selbe logisch wie deine Aussage gerade.
Nee, also ich meine, bei der Hitze kannst du davon ausgehen,
dass es wirklich einfach immer heißer wird.
Ja, gut.
Und bei der Pandemie hoffe ich, dass es wenigstens übernächstes Jahr vorbei ist.
Hm.
Aber es kann sein,
ich meine, es kann sein,
jetzt werden wir mal richtig pessimistisch,
es kann sein, dass einfach jetzt gerade irgendwo
aus irgendeiner Schweinezuchtanlage
noch ein anderes Virus überspringt
und das jetzt auch noch rumzieht.
Das ist natürlich gerade,
würde es vielleicht nicht so unbedingt auffallen, aber
das kann auch sein,
dass das jetzt schon so ein bisschen
grassiert und dann haben wir vielleicht
nächstes Jahr oder wenn wir mutig sind,
dieses Jahr von den Russen diesen
Impfstoff alle
und dann denken wir uns,
ja geil, wir sind jetzt alle immun gegen Corona
und dann haben wir einfach nächstes Jahr die
nächste Pandemie von irgendeinem Zeugswürfel halt die ganze
Zeit in irgendwelchen
Mastanlagen, irgendwelche neuen
Viren züchten. Wir haben es einfach irgendwo ein bisschen
übertrieben, ja.
Ich glaube, wir haben Peak Humanity langsam erreicht.
Aber gut, lass uns über
positive Sachen reden. Was hast du denn so in letzter Zeit
Cooles gemacht, Kejana? Positive Sachen, wenn ich
auf die Themenliste schaue.
Nee,
bei mir tut sich gerade nicht allzu viel.
Ich habe leichte berufliche Veränderungen
jetzt spontan hinter mir,
aber nur so leicht. Spontan.
Mich haben dreimal Leute gefragt, ob man hat Kejana einen neuen Job.
Ja, so halb. Also ich arbeite jetzt
bei unserem Mutterkonzern für,
zumindest bis zum Ende des Jahres.
jetzt ohne genaueren Zeitplan,
erstmal bis dahin geplant.
Und da geht es halt weniger in Richtung
ÖPNV-Tickets, sondern
den anderen ÖPNV-Kram.
Und
die Firma macht halt,
ich glaube, das ist auch kein Geheimnis, dass ich bei Harkon
da arbeite, die machen halt dieses ganze Haffa-System.
Witzigerweise, gleich am ersten Tag
vom Kollegen gezeigt bekommen,
hier ist übrigens unsere Doku für die ganzen Schnittstellen.
Und da gibt es irgendwie Leute, die versuchen, das zu
reverse-engineeren. So, ja, das war
ich, so unter anderem.
Hier ist die Doku.
Du hättest einfach was fragen müssen.
Ja, genau.
Die Fragen halt nie.
Gebt ihr die wirklich raus?
Ich habe immer noch das Gefühl, da würde halt trotzdem keiner.
Ich meine, gut, die meisten Entwickler dürfen es wahrscheinlich eh nicht,
aber es wirkt nicht so, als ob die Firma es einfach rausgeben würde.
Aber fand ich sehr geil.
Ich dachte, das ist die gleiche Firma.
Ach nee, das ist die Mutterfirma.
Okay, verstehe.
Also ich habe ja vorher bei einer anderen Firma gearbeitet, bei EOS,
und wir gehören halt zu Harkon.
Okay, verstehe.
Das heißt, du hast bloß so eine kleine Rochade gemacht.
Genau.
Aber ja, das halte ich beschränkt.
Ich bleibe auch aktuell bei EOS beschäftigt.
Aber ich finde es ganz cool,
mal ein bisschen mehr,
noch mehr auszubreiten Richtung ÖPNV-Themen
und da mal in die komplexeren Apps reinzuschauen.
Also es bleibt auch alles Richtung iOS bei mir.
Und da mal zu schauen,
die Sachen, die man wirklich in der Hand hat,
also mal guten Ticketing-Kram auch,
aber den nutze ich persönlich eher weniger,
vor allem hier in Dresden.
Weil man hat halt die Monatskarte
oder die Abo-Monatskarte,
da braucht man das halt nicht.
Aber den anderen Kram sieht man halt häufiger in Benutzung
und hat da auch ein bisschen besseres Gefühl für,
was da so existiert und wie man so Verbindungen anzeigt und Kram.
Und das ist schon hoch ekelhafte, viel Code zusammengewachsen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, du hast es hauptsächlich gemacht,
weil du mal nicht mehr Swift,
sondern mal explizit Objective-C machen wolltest, oder?
Wollen in großen Anführungsstrichen.
Das war so die eine Hemmschwelle.
Will ich das wirklich machen?
Also hast du dich jetzt nur freiwillig dafür entschieden
oder wurdest du gefragt, ob du das machen möchtest?
Ich habe schon beides.
Ich habe mich auch freiwillig dafür entschieden.
Ich hätte auch Nein sagen können.
Aber es ist auch bestens sehr interessant,
da mal reinzuschauen und mal reinzuschnuppern.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch Kram, der ist seit zehn Jahren,
seitdem die Plattform existiert, seitdem iOS existiert,
existieren diese Apps.
Beziehungsweise seitdem sind die am Entstehen und am Wachsen
und eigentlich nur am Wachsen.
Ja, das nennen wir mal eine API, die kleiner wird.
Ich habe tatsächlich heute einen PR geöffnet,
wo ich einen Bug gefixt habe
und habe dafür ausschließlich Code gelöscht.
Das sind keine einzige Zeile Coden zugefügt.
Das ist so toll, Pian.
Aber das war auch eher ein besonderer Fehl.
Aber naja.
Nicht schlecht.
Wir haben leider so ein Projekt,
was ich jetzt so ein bisschen mitgeerbt habe,
wo der Entwickler aufgehört hat.
Und irgendwie hat das Team von dem Entwickler dem erlaubt,
der Einzige zu sein, der dieses Thema bearbeitet.
Also ist der Busfaktor wirklich eins?
Quasi?
Genau.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob der Busfaktor 0 ist.
Weil ich überlege, wie viele dürfen gehen,
damit es nicht mehr geht.
Und es durfte halt keiner gehen.
So, und jetzt verteilen wir dieses Projekt so unter drei Leuten
aus unterschiedlichen Teams.
Und ich dachte eigentlich, ein anderes Team hätte das geerbt.
Und dann habe ich mich gestern mit dem zum ersten Mal unterhalten
und habe so festgestellt,
die kennen sich genauso wenig mit dem Thema aus wie ich.
Schön.
Schauen wir mal rein.
Das ist irgendein Java-Projekt,
was wir allerdings alle irgendwie benutzen.
Und da gibt es natürlich nicht mal Maven-Files oder POM oder irgend so was.
Da gibt es ein Shell-Skript, was direkt Java-C aufruft.
Oh, großartig.
Da gibt es keine Jenkins-Files.
Da gibt es die Repos, keine Readmes.
Es war einfach nur, das hat, also ich meine, das ist, die Software ist gut, aber der hat die Software jetzt so gebaut, dass die wirklich von keinem anderen einfach so.
Jobsicherheit.
Der hat sich bestimmt gedacht, jetzt so feuert mich bestimmt.
Genau, das ist auch ein bisschen spannend.
Es ist immer krass, wenn man von genau solchen Projekten hört, die sind halt auch nie, also zumindest aus der Erzählung, und ich kann ja nur von solchen Storys berichten, was ich so online gelesen habe,
Aber die sind halt gefühlt, in Anführungsstrichen,
nie so gebaut, dass sie maintainable sind von anderen Leuten.
Die sind halt immer so, wie du schon sagst,
die haben eine ganz esoterische Struktur.
Die werden auf sehr spezifische Art und Weise gebaut,
halten sich an keine Standards,
sind am besten noch komplett verwachsen,
aber funktionieren super.
Funktioniert immer fantastisch.
Also das Outcome ist großartig, aber da darf ich nicht anschauen.
Also das Ding ist ganz okay.
Es funktioniert.
Und der ist glücklicherweise auch schon seit einigen Jahren stale, der Code.
Das heißt, dass wir es einfach benutzen und es nicht wirklich verändern müssen.
Keine Bug aufgetaucht, denn die? Voll gut.
Naja, das Problem ist ein bisschen, dass wir,
das ist eine Java-Bibliothek ist, die wir,
weil sie die einzige war, die das machen
konnte, die mit dem Service sprechen konnte, halt irgendwann mal
mit GWT nach JavaScript transpilieren und deswegen
in unserer Web-Anwendung verwenden. Oh, cool.
Und in unserer Web-Anwendung
ist so gut, dass wir die jetzt auch wieder zurück in Telefone
stecken als React Native-Anwendung.
Und da haben wir jetzt so eine Library, die von A nach
B zieht und jetzt momentan
in einem Kontext läuft, wo sie wirklich nicht hingehört.
Boah, das klingt schon echt großartig.
Ich liebe es ja, dass wir irgendwie es schaffen,
in der Tech-Welt immer mehr Abstraktionsebenen
irgendwo reinzuschieben.
Ich kann diesen Blogpost empfehlen.
Don't write code that is reusable.
Write code that is easy to throw away.
Das ist ein gar nicht so falscher Grundsatz.
Ich habe das heute erst einer Kollegin wieder rausgesucht.
Es gab ein schönes Video,
das Clean Code is Dead heißt.
Weil wir überlegt haben,
das und das sieht doch gleich aus.
Da können wir doch eine Abstraktion rausziehen.
Machen wir das generisch
und da stecken wir einfach das rein und dann haben wir gesehen,
warte mal, dann müssen wir diesen Typ-Parameter,
den müssen wir auch daran machen, den müssen wir auch daran machen
und plötzlich wäre das, dann hätten wir uns
15 Zeilen Code gespart, aber die
Komplexität wäre dann natürlich in diesen 15
Zeilen trotzdem noch die gleiche, es wäre dann
einfach dichterer, komplexerer
Code. Und im Idealfall klappt das für die dritte
Stelle, wo du es brauchst, trotzdem nicht und du musst dann immer
nochmal die Abstraktion verwendet. Genau, die Aussage von diesem
und ich muss mich mal raussuchen, das hieß irgendwie
Hot Garbage Clean Code, das ist
dead.
das Mantra heißt ja, don't repeat yourself.
Dry. Der Code ist dry.
Und der Typ, der diesen
Vortrag gehalten hat, hat eigentlich das Mantra umgebracht.
The Code is so dry
that it chaves.
Also der Code ist so trocken, dass er kratzt.
Oder reibt.
Und das ist wirklich so, wenn du sagst,
okay, guck mal, ich hab hier zwei Sachen, die sind,
ich meine, das ist nur von
Fall zu Fall, aber ich hab, seitdem ich das gesehen hab,
ich hab häufiger mal bei mir festgestellt, ich könnte jetzt hier
irgendwie eine Abstraktion rausziehen und den Code irgendwie
weniger machen und dafür
aber die Komplexität wird ja nicht weniger.
Oder ich lasse es einfach dupliziert, dann kann ich nämlich
beide Seiten einfach ändern, ohne dass es irgendwie,
dass ich, ich brauche dann,
du brauchst ja noch länger, du hast, wenn du
zwei Klassen hast, die fast gleich aussehen.
Also ich will das jetzt auch kein,
ich will es nicht auf die Höhe eines Mantras erheben,
dass Leute sagen, Hendrik dupliziert immer
alles, das muss nicht immer sein.
Aber wenn du zwei einfache Klassen hast, oder Objekte
hast, oder Sachen hast, zwei einfache
Implementierungen hast, die jetzt keine
30 Zeilen lang sind, und die sind identisch.
Du kannst da irgendwie eine Abstraktion rausziehen,
dann könntest du,
wenn du es nicht machst, könntest du sagen, ach guck mal,
das sieht genauso aus wie das, fertig.
Oder du machst das Ding,
machst du zwei Sachen, die jeweils 30 Zeilen
lang sind, eine Sache, die 35 Zeilen
lang ist und dann ist
aber in manchen Fällen,
wie gesagt auch nicht immer, ist es dann aber
halt wesentlich schwieriger zu lesen.
Dann kannst du nicht einfach
bei dem einen sagen, das ist genau
das gleiche wie das, sondern denkst dann so,
ich fängst bei nur an.
Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen das Problem,
dass wir, ich weiß nicht, das fühlt sich an wie so ein Problem von Tech-Leuten,
dass wir versuchen, goldene Regeln zu finden.
Regeln, die halt immer, die halt klar anwendbar sind,
die eine klare Guideline haben, die du dir immer draufwerfen kannst
und schauen, ob man eine Ja- oder Nein-Entscheidung treffen kann.
Also unsere Gehirne sind ja darauf optimiert und trainiert,
irgendwie Patterns zu finden und Abstraktionen zu finden
und Algorithmen zu suchen.
Und dementsprechend machen wir auch sowas wie Agile-Entwicklung
mit Scrum-Meetings und Groomings und Tickets,
die durch fünf Stages gehen und Story Points.
Der Softwareentwickler ist ja quasi,
dein Gehirn ist darauf trainiert,
solche Prozesse zu finden und Prozesse zu optimieren.
Obwohl du manchmal auch sagen könntest,
ja, oder ich mache mir Musik an und schreibe das Ding halt zweimal.
Oder ich schreibe mir diese drei Tastige auf die To-Do-Liste
und nicht ins Jira und dann mache ich die einfach.
Bei dem einen Projekt hätte ich mir gewünscht,
dass der Typ gerne die Abstraktion von dem Build-Script,
was da irgendwie einmal in Shell und einmal in Bud und einmal in Shell für macOS geschrieben ist,
doch rausgezogen hätte und irgendwie ein normales Bildsystem verwendet hätte für dieses Java-Projekt.
Ja, also ich meine, gute Standards, die man schnell versteht, die halt auch plattformunabhängig funktionieren
und also auch erprobt sind, die sind schon was wert.
Aber naja, es wäre ja sonst nichts Besonderes und es wäre ja voll langweilig, wenn das einfach funktionieren würde.
Genau. Also du siehst, wir tauschen gerade Meinungen aus und reden über dies und jenes, weil wir irgendwie keine so guten Themen finden.
So ein Thema, das ich auf jeden Fall noch ansprechen will, wenn du schon so teaserst, ist diese Monstrosität auf deinem Schreibtisch, die mir da die ganze Zeit ins Auge sticht.
Was ist denn das für eine Monstrosität?
Um das mal visuell zu beschreiben, ihr kennt vielleicht so ein Bild von so einem gefühlt hart übertakteten Raspberry Pi, der so eine riesige Heatsink drauf hat.
Das da sieht aus wie fünf von denen aneinander
gesteckt, weil es so ein Mac Mini ist.
Ach, die Heatsinks liegen nur drauf.
Liegen bloß drauf. Aber wie viel sind das?
Vier mal vier? Vier mal fünf.
Vier mal fünf. 20 Heatsinks,
die auf diesem Mac Mini liegen.
Das sieht einfach großartig aus.
Ja, es ist
warm. Und ich habe
mir dieses Gerät geholt und ich spiele manchmal
tatsächlich StarCraft damit.
Ach, du spielst StarCraft auf dem Ding? Wenn die CPU
auf Leistung ist, dann geht der Lüfter an.
Wenn die
wenn die GPU auf Leistung geht,
geht der Lüfter irgendwie nicht an und das Ding wird einfach
warm. Und da dachte ich mir, oh, es ist schon
tolle warm. Also, der scheint sich nicht drüber zu beschweren,
aber es ist schon tolle warm. Und jetzt könnte ich mal,
du kannst mal eins von den Dingern in die Hand nehmen.
Oh, die sind ja gut geheizt.
So, dann dachte ich mir, naja, ich könnte ja vielleicht irgendeine Art
Heating drauflegen und da irgendwie ein Ventilator daneben halten.
Und dann habe ich die, man kann
immer schwer einschätzen, wie groß die Dinger sind,
wenn man die bei Amazon bestellt. Ach, das ist ein typischer Fall
davon gewesen. Und dann dachte ich mir, wie groß wird das wohl
sein? Und ich habe auch nicht
gelesen, dass es so eine
20er-Packung ist.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, naja, wenn ich die einfach alle hier so drauf lege,
dann, ich habe mir mal irgendwann überlegt, man könnte ja so schön
abwechselndes Pattern, wenn man die mal so rum und mal so rum legt.
Wie so ein Schaubstoff für
Soundproofing. Genau.
Aber wenn es da
einmal drauf liegt, ich brauche es auch nicht immer, aber es sieht ganz
nett aus und dann halte ich hier manchmal einen Ventilator
drauf. Hast du mal eine Messung gemacht,
was die CPU sagt? Also der hat ja
bestimmt so 20 Thermometer drin überall.
Ja, ich habe mir nicht die einzelnen Sachen angeguckt,
aber jetzt habe ich gerade, ich meine, jetzt mache ich
das geht schon.
Das ist spannend.
Aber man merkt schon, dass da irgendwie ein bisschen was rauskommt.
Das Ding ist schon warm obendrauf.
Ist bald blöd.
Krass. Apropos, ich habe jetzt auch schon wieder
einen schönen Tweet gesehen, wenn du schon meinst, man weiß ja nicht,
wie groß die sind von so jemandem, der ist
im Komma verrutscht und hat sich für seine Bohrmaschine,
also im professionellen Kontext hier,
irgendwo Baugewerbe, weiß nicht was,
für seine Bohrmaschine so ein, wie nennt man das,
so ein Bohrkopf, so ein Dings halt
bestellt, ein Bohrer.
Und ist da wohl
Komma verrutscht bei der Bestellung und das Ding
war nicht 4,5 Millimeter,
sondern 45
also, nee, das sah breiter aus.
Zentimeter dann oder was? Also das war locker hier
4,5 Zentimeter breit.
Also vorne. Also das ist ein
richtiger, wie man so schön sagt, Oschi.
Die meine
in der Hand.
Ich meine, das hat ja sicherlich auch das
10-20-fache gekostet, aber wenn man gut
einmal im Komma schon verrutscht, dann
ist das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so weit weg.
Das ist wie die Geschichte, dass der Spinat
gar nicht so einen Eisenanteil hat.
Stimmt, das war auch ein Komma-Fehler.
Das war angeblich ein Komma-Fehler, aber es war
glaube ich auch vielleicht einfach irgendeine Verunreinigung
oder sowas.
Genau. Was ist denn sonst noch so
passiert in letzter Zeit?
Gerade so vor ein paar Tagen hat
Mozilla schon schön in die
Medien geschafft.
Schön in die Medien geschafft. Ich habe sehr viele
weinende Emojis auf Twitter gesehen, muss ich sagen.
Also
schön war das nicht. Die haben ja, was ich auch
nicht wusste, tausend Mitarbeiter anscheinend beschäftigt
und haben ein Viertel davon
rausgeschmissen. So relativ spontan.
Die Leute wussten auch, also hat sich vorher nicht abgezeichnet,
sondern es war eine sehr spontane Entscheidung.
Und wie sich im Nachhinein oder währenddessen
dann rausgestellt hat, auch sehr interessant
durchgeschnitten durch die Firma, wer da
rausgeschmissen wurde und wer nicht.
Es wurden manche Projekte ausgedünnt,
es wurden manche Projekte komplett verweist.
Genau, also von den Core Firefox-Entwicklern
ist, glaube ich, niemand gegangen.
Aber zum Beispiel die ganzen Rust-Leute, die noch da waren,
beziehungsweise das Servo-Team, die sind komplett weg.
Das Servo-Team ist angeblich komplett weg.
Und auch sehr witzig, dass das Incident Response Team
ist komplett weg. Also wenn irgendwie Lücken
jetzt auftauchen, niemand ist da,
der sich darum kümmern kann.
Ist doch ein Secure Webbrowser.
Gerade für das Tor-Projekt,
das auch drauf aufbaut, das ist doch mega beschissen.
Ja, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass so eine Spekulation ist, dass
vielleicht andere Projekte, dass die das
jetzt weitermachen und irgendwie es mit unterstützen.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was die
Intentionen...
Vielleicht kann man da wirklich
ein Servo-Startup draus machen, war ja auch eine Empfehlung von manchen Leuten
ich weiß nicht, ob das realistisch ist oder nicht, aber
es wäre cool. Der eine
Safari-Entwickler,
es gibt nur einen Safari-Entwickler.
Der meint Ricky, der eine, der auf Twitter immer recht aktiv ist?
Ricky Mandela?
Der ist auch bei den ganzen, der ist auch bei den
Konferenzen, der Vertreter von Safari.
Das weiß ich halt gar nicht, aber der arbeitet auch immer auf Safari.
Ich glaube, Safari hat bloß einen Entwickler.
So wie alle Projekte bei Apple.
Der hat neulich auch gesagt,
ja, vielleicht wollt ihr bei uns was probieren wollt,
bei Safari. Ich habe überlegt, Safari
auf Servobasis wäre auch cool.
Ja, not gonna happen.
Aber wer weiß,
das hier Webkit umbauen,
wäre sicherlich ganz cool.
Es gibt Branches
für Rust-Code-Projekte in
Chrome. Also Firefox
ist tatsächlich nicht der einzige
Browser in letzter Zeit. Es gibt so ein paar Sachen,
die Chrome experimentiert hat.
Ob jetzt schon irgendwie tatsächlich
Rust-Code in Chrome drin ist, möchte ich
nicht behaupten. Aber Google ist an der Front
ja auch recht aktiv. Das stimmt.
Ihr Fuchsia-System ist auch zur Hälfte.
in Rust gebaut.
Gibt es da eigentlich mal Neuigkeiten, was mit Fuchsia
passiert?
Das ist ja nie irgend so was richtig Konkretes
gesagt worden. Das köchelt so vor sich hin und
keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Es kann sein, dass
bei der nächsten Google I.O. Google sagt,
wir haben jetzt kein Linux-Konnel mehr oder so.
Das könnte eventuell
sein, keine Ahnung.
Krass.
Ich bin kein Android-Typ.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber das wäre mal spannend. Also wenn wir da irgendwen kennen,
könnten wir vielleicht mal jemanden einladen.
Ich bin ja neulich angesprochen worden
von
Florian Giecher, den wir hier zu Gast hatten.
Ah ja, wir müssen mal wieder eine neue Folge
gemeinsam machen und so an der Messenger-Front
ist mal wieder was einiges passiert.
Was ist da denn passiert?
Ja, es gibt zum Beispiel keinen Riot mehr.
Ach so, ja, die haben es einfach umbenannt
zu Element.
Obwohl dann irgendwie das Internet zur Hälfte noch
sehr unglücklich drüber ist.
Auch so mit so guten Gründen wie, ja, das ist ja
voll nicht googelbar. Die haben das gerade erst
umbenannt, lass dir mal ein bisschen Zeit.
Aber nein,
Ich finde das Redesign
sehr angenehm von
Desktop-Element bzw. Web-Element.
Finde ich,
war sehr gut getimt,
weil es auch eins, also passt großartig
zu macOS Big Sur, was sie ja auch da
großartig zum
UI-Redesign da, finde ich sehr
schick auf der Beta.
Ansonsten hat sich ja glaube ich nicht viel getan
bis auf Name und Optik
so ein bisschen, aber Grund
am Unterbau nicht wirklich was, das geht
ja schleichend immer weiter.
Ja, also ich hatte vor allem die Experience,
dass das Umbenennen
von dieser App halt so ein bisschen nervig
war. Ich hatte das, wenn du es in deiner Taskbar
drin hast, irgendwie dann verschwindet es
plötzlich. Oder beziehungsweise,
du machst ein Update, du sagst dem Ding,
das Ding sagt dir, mach mal ein Update.
Und dann sagst du, okay, und dann startet es neu.
Und dann ist es halt ein neues Icon
in der Taskbar.
Und du hast dieses kaputte Fragezeichen, weil das die App
nicht mehr so heißt. Und dann hieß es ein paar Tage lang,
hieß es Element in Klammern
Riot. Genau, ein Update lang haben die
den Beinamen beibehalten, damit du es halt noch findest
mit Spotlight oder anderen Launchern. Genau, und
dann haben sie es nochmal umeinander, da hatte ich noch wieder
dieses Fragezeichen. Gleich mit dem
nächsten Update haben die das Riot wieder rausgelegt. Okay,
das ging zügig, aber...
Und auf dem Telefon hatte ich die Situation, dass ich
mir, da war ich gerade unterwegs,
dachte ich mir, gut, kann ich mal
Riot installieren? Und dann fiel mir ein, warte mal,
ich muss mich ja irgendwie selber signen und
irgendwie
das Cross-Signing
selber machen. Und da gab es halt diese Situation,
ich könnte das über einen QR-Code machen und dann hatte ich
genau dieses Bild da vor Augen, quasi
XKCD
1237.
Eine App, die sagt, um
das hier zu machen oder to install this app, scan
this QR-Code auf dem Bildschirm von deinem Handy.
Wie kriegt man
How to freak out
mobile App-Users?
Aber die Kamera ist auf der anderen
Seite. Was mache ich? Du könntest dir
eine Konstruktion mit vier Spiegeln ausdenken.
Es gibt
ausfährt. Vielleicht könnte man die dann so rumbiegen.
Also klicken.
Und das abbrichst.
Nee, und dann hab ich irgendwie mit hin und
her pasten, mit hin und her springen
zwischen zwei Apps, hab ich geschaut, ob die Emojis
alignen und dann hab ich geguckt, okay, ich hab
jetzt die eine, das Riot
mit dem Element
verifiziert, na ganz toll.
Dann musstest du das deinstallieren.
Ach, naja, das ist wahr, es geht.
Aber jetzt haben wir, jetzt haben wir schön, jetzt haben wir einen neuen Messenger,
der nicht mehr Riot heißt.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass du mit dem Namen Riot,
gerade im Zuge der letzten Monate,
in den politischen Ereignissen der letzten Monate
so ein bisschen unzufrieden waren, weil es halt
tatsächlich Riots gab auf der Straße und der
Begriff nicht mehr so unbedingt
positiv assoziiert war. Also nicht, dass der Begriff
Riot jemals positiv assoziiert war, aber
wenn du den ganzen Tag über Riots redest und das assoziierst
mit Leuten, denen es schlecht geht und die deshalb
auf die Straße gehen und irgendwie Macy's Stores
anzünden, dann
möchtest du dein Produkt
verständlicherweise nicht mehr unbedingt
rioten. Das ist gut möglich. Finde ich auch in Ordnung.
Element ist ja kein schlechter Name an der Stelle.
Nee, da gab es ja irgendwie eine Linux-Distribution oder sowas.
Ach so, Elementary OS gibt es.
Ach stimmt, das heißt Elementary.
Ich fand das eigentlich, Elementary OS finde ich früher ganz cool.
Ich habe das schon ewig nicht mehr angeschaut.
Ich habe nur, dass die irgendwas hatten mit so einem Bezahl-App-Store.
Stimmt, ich dachte, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich der Messenger für Elementary OS.
Das wäre witzig.
Aber na gut, okay, Element.
Aber was hat Element mit Matrix oder Vektor?
Vektor heißt ja auch nicht mehr Vektor.
Die haben ja auch die Firma gleich mit umbenannt, to Element.
Stimmt.
Also es gibt jetzt nur noch Matrix als das Protokoll und Element für die Firma, die das hauptsächlich baut, ich weiß nicht, ob es die Element Foundation jetzt heißt, vielleicht auch nicht, weiß ich nicht, und die Messenger, also die Referenzimplementierung.
Ist Element Foundation dann eigentlich Atom? Oder ist es dann Quark?
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht kannst du auch dann...
Wenn das Produkt Element heißen, die einzelnen Komponenten von dann Atom? Natürlich, es ist auf Atom basiert.
Vielleicht kannst du die
Übersicht über die Element Clients,
den Periodic Table,
genau.
Es sind bestimmt Libraries drin.
Jetzt müsst ihr in Elektron,
nee, jetzt müsst ihr in Atom, achso, stimmt.
Atom basiert auf Elektron.
Und wenn dann mehrere, jetzt bräuchten wir
Komponenten, die Neutrons heißen, damit wir daraus
Element zusammenbauen können.
Cool.
Gut, lassen wir das.
Element ist ja auch auf Elektron basiert,
da geht es ja schon um die Verbindung.
Zumindest die Desktop-Variante. Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall.
Naja, aber so viel hat sich ansonsten
Messenger-mäßig nicht getan, oder? Also die Dinger
werden natürlich weiterentwickelt.
Neue Matrix-Clients
gibt es eigentlich in letzter Zeit auch nicht wirklich.
Und große Feature-Sprünge.
Aber das Rumor-Projekt scheint
nicht mehr ganz so tot zu sein, oder?
Achso, da habe ich keinen mitbekommen.
Da scheinen irgendwie Leute wieder
Calls for Participation auf der
This Week in Rust-Mailing-Riste zu.
Ah, da habe ich gar nicht mehr sprungen.
Aber das ist jetzt auch nichts, was
irgendwie einen Hörer
befriedigen würde, weil ich jetzt auch nichts darüber
erzählen kann, außer hören und sagen.
Das ist doch das Fundament
unseres Podcasts.
Es ist eine schicke Sache passiert. Ich habe ja diese
Library, darüber könnte ich mal kurz erzählen. Ich habe in letzter Zeit
relativ wenig, es ist ja auch schönes Wetter draußen,
relativ wenig zum Hobby-Coden
gekommen. Aber
ich habe ja diese eine Library, meine allererste
ursprüngliche Rust-Library, die ich angefangen habe,
diese Desktop-Notification-Geschichte, die irgendwie
D-Bus-Nachrichten verschickt.
Und es gibt jetzt
von einem Typen,
der auf dem Rustfest schon drüber gesprochen
hat, eine Library, die
eine reine
Rust-basierte
Debus-Library ist. Das heißt,
die, die ich jetzt momentan verwende, ist
auf lib-Debus basiert.
Das ist also eine C-Library, die dann rangelinkt wird.
Da sind einfach die Bindings davon.
Da gibt es irgendwie mehr als nur Bindings.
Das Ding ist schon eine umfangreichere
Geschichte, aber es hat auch eine fiese
API. Und jetzt gibt es
eine pure Rust-Variante davon.
Da dachte ich mir, kann ich mal ein paar Tage
hinsetzen und das mal aufräumen. Da habe ich erst mal angefangen
zu refactoren,
denn
das Ding ist angefangen als pure,
als nur für Linux gedachte Library.
Du sagst jetzt hier, bau mir eine Notification
und dann mit Bilderpattern so Sätze,
Titel, Summary, vielleicht kannst du noch ein Bild
hinzufügen für Bild.
Bild sind hinter Features, da kannst du dann irgendwie
unter Rust schreibst du dann oben noch, wenn dieses
Feature gesetzt ist, dann importiere das. Da hast du so
Build-Dependencies
drin und dann kam
jemand auf die Idee, ich möchte aber noch Mac-Support,
ach, das war ich, Mist.
Und dann kam aber irgendwie
neulich ja noch irgendwie einer aus diesem Tauri-Projekt
auf mich zu und hat gesagt, ja, Windows-Support wäre auch noch schön
und irgendwann war dieser, der Kopf
von der LibRS
so ein Monster von so Bildweichen,
wo drinsteint, wenn
Mac dann das und wenn
Linux ist,
nicht wirklich Linux, sondern wenn Unix,
aber nicht Mac, weil es könnte Linux oder
BSD sein, dann das
und wenn Unix,
aber nicht Mac und das
Feature Images, dann auch noch diese
Dependency, das zog sich so 30
Zeilen hin und es wurde immer schlimmer
und du hast dann überall kleine
Weichen gehabt und deswegen, jetzt habe ich mir gedacht,
okay, ich möchte diese
Linux-Dependency D-Bus-RS
da rausbauen.
Wie fange ich da jetzt an?
Ich sollte vielleicht eine Weiche machen, damit ich erstmal das
nebeneinander testen kann, dass es beides noch
funktioniert und vielleicht hole ich
mal eine Version an die Leute, die es benutzen wollen, raus,
wo ich das Z-Bus
Z-Bus als optionales Feature
anmache, wo du sagen kannst, wenn ich es mit diesem Feature baue,
dann benutze ich diese Dependency, diese D-Bus
Dependency nicht mehr, sondern die Z-Bus Dependency.
Plötzlich hatte ich irgendwie
noch eine
Option, noch ein Vektor mehr, wo
sich alles drum modifiziert hat. Da dachte ich mir,
okay, jetzt kann ich das erstmal lassen.
Das geht so nicht. Ich fange jetzt an,
die ganzen
Plattformen eigenen Dependencies
rauszuziehen. Dann habe ich irgendwie alles,
alles, was Mac ist, in einem Untermodul gemacht
und gesagt,
wenn Mac, dann bindest du dieses Modul
ein und dann muss ich innerhalb von dem Modul keine
Weichen mehr machen.
Und wenn du Linux
bist, dann baust du dieses Modul in Windows
und dann habe ich quasi einen Tag lang mich nur damit
beschäftigt, irgendwie erstmal alles wirklich sauber
wieder auseinander zu klamüsern und auf unterschiedliche
Module aufzuteilen, um dann
anzufangen, das Linux-Debus-Modul
zu duplizieren und das nochmal neu zu bauen,
nicht mit der Debus-Library, sondern mit der etwas
doch solle anders aussehende Z-Bus-Library.
Genau, und darauf bin ich
dann auch mal ein bisschen stecken geblieben,
bis als ich gemerkt habe, dass die Z-Bus-Library leider
noch nicht alle Features unterstützt, die ich brauche.
Ah, shit, ja, okay.
So, das verfolge ich jetzt
gerade so ein bisschen, aber es ist cool.
Jetzt haben wir auch wieder fünf
Weichen drin für unterschiedliche Features.
Jetzt kommt noch der
Felix, der Maintainer von der
Mac Notification
Library auf mich zu und sagt, guck mal, hier ist jemand
anders, der plötzlich contributed
das Ding auf, ich glaube sogar vielleicht auf die
neuen Mac Notification APIs umstellen
und dann kriegst du plötzlich die und die Features mit dazu.
Review das mal bitte. Und ich so,
ja, okay, mache ich.
Das war irgendwie vor anderthalb
Wochen und seitdem bin ich auch wieder nicht mehr dazu gekommen.
Ich habe das auch gesehen. Ich habe ja auch das Weibo gewatched.
Aber kannst du mir ja
helfen, das zu reviewen.
Ja, weil ich dafür viel Ahnung von habe.
Ich schaue gerne mal mit rein.
Ach, siehst du, so kriegt man Leute,
zu partizipieren.
Ich habe ja auch selber mal versucht,
eine kleine Swift-Library zu schreiben,
die quasi nur so diese Notification-API
rappt, weil es halt ekelhaft ist auf macOS.
Also wenn du jetzt keine
normale App-Kit-App
bist und du willst
Notifications schicken über den Notification-Center,
das ist echt nicht so schön.
Du musst halt quasi eine App
vortäuschen und
da halt haufenweise Sachen, du musst quasi
eine kleine App mitbundeln,
die bloß als Dummy da existiert. Das ist echt eklig.
Genau, das ist irgendwie das Problem,
dass du nicht einfach sagen kannst,
ich schicke jetzt eine Notification und ich heiße,
ich schicke die im Namen dieser App,
sondern du musst tatsächlich irgendwie irgendwas installiert haben
im System, um nachweisen zu können,
dass du das auch wirklich bist.
Das geht wahrscheinlich, wenn diese Library, die du baust,
irgendjemand verwendet und dann seine eigene...
Ja, aber dann brauchst du es halt gar nicht mehr,
weil die Apple APIs für die Notification Center,
die sind halt, also es gibt zwei,
das ist immer ein bisschen verwirrend,
weil es gibt diesen Notification Center,
was historisch gesehen was ganz anderes ist.
Das ist mehr so ein Framework,
was im System steckt, wo du
Nachrichten zwischen Prozessen
und zwischen Teilen deiner Applikationen
her schicken kannst. Und dann
gibt es die User Notifications. Genau, also
das ist dann quasi D-Bus.
Ah, okay, das wusste ich gar nicht. D-Bus ist
einfach ein, für
XDG nenne ich es mal,
also für Cross-Desktop,
für diese Cross-Desktop-Gruppe, also alles was
KDE, Gnome, XFCE,
alle Linux-Distributionen
oder alle Linux-Desktop-
Distributionen und alle BSD
die benutzen für
IPC, für
Cross-Process
Communication, benutzen diesen komischen
Debus. Und das
kannst du benutzen, damit
du irgendwie der mit deinem
Widget auf deinem Desktop oder in deiner Taskbar
deinem Player sagen kann, Pause und
Play, oder damit der zurückkommunizieren kann, ich spiele
gerade dieses Lied und hier ist ein Bild dazu oder da ist die
Lautstärke davon. Sowas geht alles über Debus.
Und die ganzen Desktop-Environments
implementieren alle einen, so ein
org.free-Desktop
.notification-Interface,
wo dann nochmal drei Funktionen,
das ist einfach so ein RPC-Framework,
wo dann nochmal drei Funktionen dahinter gerappt sind.
Und wenn du die aufrufst,
genau das ist das, was meine Lib eigentlich nur macht,
dann kannst du da was drauf aufrufen
und dann
macht das Ding,
macht eigentlich deinen XFCE oder dein KDE
oder dein Gnome, macht dann die Desktop-Notification.
Aber nee, genau das ist das, was
der Notifications-Interface eigentlich ist auf macOS
beziehungsweise auch auf iOS, also kannst du auch typischerweise,
es ist immer so ein bisschen altbacken, wenn man damit was machen muss,
weil das sind halt uralte APIs, die gibt es halt seit Urzeiten.
Auf iOS-Solver kriegst du Notifications, sobald das Keyboard gekommen ist.
Und dann kannst du halt schauen, wo das Keyboard auf dem Dillstrip ist
und es ist halt eklig, damit zu arbeiten, gerade so im UI-Kontext, finde ich.
Aber es gab halt, als das ins Leben gerufen wurde,
noch nicht diesen Notification-Center auf den Plattformen,
wo man halt mit User-Notifications umgeht, deswegen heißt das halt so.
Damals gab es noch Growl, das kenne ich noch auf macOS.
Genau.
Das war richtig eklig.
Aber das war halt der Standard damals.
und das war halt witzig, wie lange sich das noch
durchgezogen hat, beziehungsweise ich habe letztens erst irgendeine App runtergeladen,
da konntest du in den Einstellungen switchen,
ob du Notifications über den Notification Center
bekommen möchtest oder über Growl, als ob heute
noch irgendjemand Growl installiert hat.
Aber war noch mit drin.
Worauf wollte ich eigentlich hinaus?
Die macOS User Notifications.
Die modernisieren sich jetzt langsam oder gibt es
eine neue API für? Die API ist echt
nicht verkehrt, damit zu arbeiten.
Es ist super easy, eine Notification zu schicken.
Du kannst auch, also die ist relativ ähnlich, glaube ich,
auf macOS, zwei OS, du kannst Dinge
was schedulen, du kannst lokale Notifications schicken,
also dass du quasi sagst, ich möchte hier
um die und die Uhrzeiten eine Notification schicken,
bla bla bla, auch komplett auf dem Gerät
geschedult haben, typischerweise kriegt man ja
auf Mobilgeräten, redet man eher über Push-Notifications
von außen, aber das geht halt alles
über denselben Fu. Naja, das ist ein Service,
der einfach diese Push-Notification
empfängt und dir dann in eine Desktop-Notification
umbaut. Genau, genau, und die APIs dafür sind klasse,
aber die halt wegzuwrappen, dass du die nicht aus einer App
heraus schicken kannst, sondern finanzierend
aus oder von sonst vielen Projekten,
gut, was weiß ich, hat man noch andere Projekte, die nicht so
keine Ahnung, also
mir wird gerade gar kein Beispiel einnehmen als CLI,
was halt die Notifications auf deinem System
schicken möchte. Das Problem so ein bisschen von dem Projekt
bei mir ist, dass ich das gebaut
habe, weil ich vor Jahren einen Spaß-Use-Case dafür
hatte, wo ich halt dieses Catch-My-Bus bauen wollte,
wo du jetzt von deinem Service startest, der einfach regelmäßig
Desktop-Notifications benutzen muss, weil es ist irgendwie
UI, wo du nicht
wirklich UI für bauen musst.
Du sagst einfach, zeig mal was an.
Das ist eine kleine Utility-App. Genau, eine kleine Utility.
Auf Linux kannst du da auch Buttons drauf tun.
Da kannst du sagen, da gibst du einfach Action,
einen Namen an und was dann passieren soll.
Beziehungsweise du kriegst dann ein Signal zurück.
Und genau dieses mit den Signalen ist dann ein Feature,
was jetzt in der Zbus-Library noch nicht da ist.
Okay.
Du kannst also sagen, hier sind Actions drin,
da schreibst du einfach nur Strings rein
und dann subscribes du dich selbst auf Signale.
Und wenn in diesem Signal dieser String wieder drin ist,
dann weißt du, dass der Button gedrückt wurde.
Interessant.
Und dann habe ich aber dieses Catch-My-Bus-In-Rust
nie zu Ende gebaut.
Aber diese Library dachte mir, da kriege ich bestimmt Punkte irgendwo.
wenn ich so eine Library pflege.
Keine Kamera-Punkte bekommen.
Aber es ist auch generell cool. Ich meine, das wird ja auch genutzt.
Man sieht es ja immer wieder, dass du da, also wir reden
ja nicht das erste Mal darüber, dass Leute halt diese Library
benutzen und in diverse Projekte mit einziehen.
Ja, für so ein Kommando-Zeit-Tool ist es zum Beispiel cool.
Du baust irgendwas,
wo du einen Build-Job startest
und dann kriegst du gezeigt, dass der fertig ist
oder sowas.
Ich wollte das in Cargo Watch mal einbauen.
Das gab es ja auch für so ein Ruby-Projekt, wo du einfach so
ein Watch startest, ein Build-Compile-Watch
und dann kriegst du Desktop-Notifications
wenn der Compile fertig ist oder wenn die Tests durchgelaufen
sind oder wenn sie rot oder grün
war, gerade wenn du es permanent anhast,
dann schreibst du eine Zeile, speicherst
und dann macht es unten einen Klick und dann hast du ein grünes
OK oder sowas. Der Friend of the Show
Vincent hat sowas ja auch mal für Swift gebaut,
Swift Watch, was auch super cool funktioniert.
Ich habe auch in Go mal, also ich mal
Go gemacht habe vor
einer Weile, da gab es so ein richtig
cooles Tool. Ich habe leider keinem lassen, wie das hieß.
Das war auch so ein Watcher, der die Tests ausgeführt
hat, aber der hatte direkt einen lokalen Web-Simmer
gestartet und dir so eine richtig, richtig
schicke Web-Oberfläche für deine Tests angezeigt.
Natürlich, die Go-Leute machen immer schicke
Web-Oberflächen. Und du hast halt das
quasi in der Festnahme
offen gehabt, diese Web-Oberfläche und
das war halt, also irgendwie waren
die Tests auch für die Projekte zumindest, die ich
da gemacht habe, so unglaublich flink, dass du halt
on safe, hat sich diese Seite aktualisiert
und war bam, alles grün und da einer rot oder so.
Und das war halt so immer on safe im Editor,
so innerhalb von weniger als einer
halben Sekunde alle Tests durch. Das war schon, also
so macht Test-Dream-Development auch Spaß.
Go ist schon geil, oder?
Das will ich nicht sagen.
Naja, aber
was, also
du kannst jetzt gerne wieder Go renten, aber was mir gerade so
auffällt, ist eigentlich, was mich immer begeistert ist,
wenn du so ein Go-Projekt hast, sei das ja auch sowas wie
GOG oder also,
die Projekte haben immer, ich glaube ja, die
Go-Entwickler sind eigentlich heimliche
doch so Web-Entwickler. Das sind immer
geile User-Interfaces aus dem Web-Browser
raus mit attached. Oder sagst, okay, da geht
plötzlich ein Server auf oder so ein Browser-Fenster
auf und die UI ist dann einfach
Webservice, der gestattet wird. Scheint genug für
in Go schon vorhanden zu sein.
Ich glaube, das ist aber auch so ein Ding, dass du halt die
nötigen Bausteine, so wie deine Notification Library
halt einfach schon existieren und die Leute da
cool, schnell, richtig coolen Kram zusammenstecken
können, ohne jetzt hier jedes Mal
wieder das Rad von vorne zu erfinden.
Genau, das ist auch das, was mich so ein bisschen
inhibited hat
bei vielen Projekten, dass ich immer dachte,
da war ich dann auch religiös.
Ja, ich möchte das in Rust machen. Das andere
ist ja gar nicht. Und dann denkst du aber
dafür gibt es aber das nicht.
Das gibt es auch noch nicht.
Fünf Jahre später ist das meiste Zeug
alles da. Und dann fängst du halt an,
da müsste ich mir erst mal sowas selber bauen.
Bei Go hast du so ein Problem.
Nicht wirklich, weil viel einfach schon
dabei ist oder weil es einfach mit viel mehr
High-Level-Zeugs kam.
Ich weiß, das war ja auch nicht alles Teil der Standard-Level-BG.
Es gab einfach super.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe
nicht sonderlich spät mit Go angefangen.
Das ist ja jetzt auch, keine Ahnung, fünf Jahre her oder so,
dass ich den Kram, dass ich ja Spaß hatte.
Ja, ihr hört übrigens immer noch akronomisierbar.
Aber damals gab es halt so eine unglaubliche Fülle an allem.
Da war halt literally alles schon vorhanden.
Egal, wonach du gesucht hast, es gab dafür,
ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen, ein Package für.
Ich glaube, es waren Go-Packages.
Go-Beans.
Gott, dafür ist gerade irgendwo ein Go-Entwickler gestorben.
Für diese Aussage.
Nee, aber es gab literally alles schon fertig.
Ich glaube, das war sogar irgendwie so eine Aussage,
dass schon mehr Go-Packages existieren als Ruby.
Gems, was mich damals
irritiert hat, weil
das Ecosystem gab es ja schon viel, viel länger.
Ich dachte, das lag daran, dass
das einfach alles doppelt und dreifach gezählt wurde,
weil es keine Registry gab
und einfach für eine neue Version immer geforkt werden musste.
Ja, und kein Versioning.
Das ist immer noch mein Lieblingsaspekt.
Ich meine, ich weiß, das ist nicht
mehr aktuell, aber
dass du, du machst ja
keine Breaking Changes, wenn du eine neue Version rausbringen willst,
dann denkst du dir einen neuen Namen aus und bringst die
Library nur raus ist. Also wer sich dieser
Aussage allein schon ausgedacht hat. Das habe ich aber
auch unabhängig davon, selbst wenn es das
gab, habe ich das ein, zwei Mal
selbst im Rust-Kontext gesehen. Da gab es irgendwie
es gab
TinyString oder
sowas oder TinyVec. Das ist dann
einfach eine String-Implementierung oder eine Vektor-Implementierung
mit so einer
Tiny-Optimierung.
Das heißt, wenn dein String oder dein Vektor
kleiner ist als eine Adresse,
dann allokiert es gar nicht, sondern
dann steht einfach an der Stelle, wo die Adresse
stehen würde, steht einfach dein String.
Dann ist das Ding für kleine
Sachen super schnell, weil es keine
Allokationen machen muss.
Da gab es irgendwie ein Projekt, das heißt
SmallVac, auf den Namen
lege ich mich nicht fest, und dann hat irgendwann der gesagt,
naja, warte mal, wir haben das jetzt mal geändert und jetzt hat es
irgendwie eine andere API und jetzt ist es
nicht mehr unsafe, bring jetzt mal eine neue
Version raus und die ist dann
MikroString oder sowas.
Da habe ich dann auch gefragt,
Hättest du das Ding nicht 2.0 nennen können?
Ihr habt doch Versionen.
Sprichst du dann dagegen, die Version zu nutzen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Naja, dann muss ja jemand die Version updaten
und dann ist das ja kaputt.
Ob du die Version von 1 nach 2 änderst
oder ob du vorne den Namen von dem einen auf das andere änderst.
Das finde ich schade,
dass diese Package Registries auch mit so viel Müll zugeparkt sind.
Wo es heißt, nimm nicht das, sondern nimm das.
das da ist jetzt deprecated, wir machen jetzt
nur noch das, dann denke ich mir so,
warum nehmt ihr das nicht weiter und
macht einfach eine neue Version?
Es ist ja nicht so, als ob die Leute aus Versehen
auf die neue inkompatible Version updaten
oder sowas.
Jetzt gehst du auf diese Lid, findest, oh, es gibt
Small weg oder Tiny weg oder Micro weg
oder String,
benutze ich das mal. Und du weißt
einfach gar nicht, dass es bereits eine bessere, schönere Version gibt,
sondern du musst
trotzdem
weiter und dann noch das Falsche, weil es ist ja die aktuellste
Version.
Das ist schon impotiert. Ja, es gibt sicherlich auch
gute Gründe dafür. Ja, es wird wahrscheinlich
häufig daran liegen, dass das unterschiedliche Leute sind und die nicht
sagen, da geht nicht der eine auf den anderen zu
und sagt, guck mal, du kannst es auch so
und so bauen,
ohne an Safecode oder ohne
diese Einschränkungen, aber man muss halt eine neue
Version von rausbringen oder sowas. Hier, lass uns mal
zusammenarbeiten. Nee, die sagen einfach,
ach guck mal, ich baue das jetzt auch und ich
veröffentliche jetzt meins unter dem Namen.
Das wäre cool, wenn, also wahrscheinlich nicht
cool, aber ich hatte gerade den Gedanken, dass das Version
halt nicht einfach nur so eine Kette von Versionsnummern
sind, sondern dass du halt auch
so baumähnlich wegforken kannst.
Das sind zwei dimensionale Versionen. Genau, dass du halt
so zwei Versionen, also es gibt die Version 2,
2.0 A und 2.0 B,
aber es sind halt beides Weiterentwicklungen davon, aber die haben
jetzt unterschiedliche Ideen, die
sie sich weiterentwickeln. Das geht doch ohne weiteres
jetzt schon. Du kannst eine Version 2, eine Version 3 rausbringen
und dann kannst du eine Version 2.1,
2.3, 2.4 rausbringen.
Das wirkt ja so, als ob die miteinander irgendwie
zu tun haben, dass das 2.1 die Weiterentwicklung
von 2.0 ist, obwohl es potenziell ja gar nicht mehr ist.
kompatibel mit dem anderen. Also Semantic Versioning
erlaubt dir das schon ohne weiteres.
Man könnte es natürlich auch einfach da ein bisschen Platz lassen,
dass du Version 2 zu Version 3 updatest
und gleichzeitig existiert schon Version 500
und 501 und 502.
So wie bei Winamp 5.
Genau, also mein Team macht die
ungeraden Versionen und das Team macht die
gerade Version.
Und dann kommt das andere Team dazwischen und nicht nur die
Fibonacci-Zahl.
Die ist schon geparkt.
Wir nehmen die, die Schaltjahre werden.
Großartig.
Aber wo du gerade übrigens meintest,
von wegen so aus religiösen Gründen in Rust neu schreiben,
da gab es vor ein paar Tagen ein cooles Projekt,
habe ich auf Wacker News gesehen,
Git Oxide, wo jemand tatsächlich dahergegangen ist
und komplett die SLA von Git neu geschrieben hat in Pure Rust.
Ja, da habe ich mich erst mal verlesen
und Gituzid oder sowas gelesen.
Ich finde es cool.
Also ich meine, sowas muss natürlich nicht existieren,
weil jemand Git doof findet.
Aber ich finde es schön, dass man so Dinge mal neu denkt.
Auch so komplexere Sachen wie eben Git,
das ja relativ viel auch macht.
Eine relativ komplexe,
eine relativ komplexe Oberfläche hat für den Nutzer auch.
Und da steckt halt natürlich ziemlich viel Arbeit mit dahinter.
Aber finde ich sehr cool, so etwas auch mal anzugehen
und so etwas zu machen und mal zu evaluieren.
Und hier aber auch vor allem die,
ich will nicht sagen das UI,
aber die, wie nennt man das denn nicht,
die API, das Human Interface.
Wie heißt denn das?
Das Wort, das ich suche, wie ein Mensch damit interagiert.
UX.
Ja, aber sprichst du von UX mit einer CLI?
Ja.
Das ist ja auch eine User Experience.
Ja, quasi die UX mal neu denken
von einer Git-CLI.
Das war eigentlich so die erste Überlegung, die ich gemacht habe, als ich festgestellt habe,
man kann mit Clab schön Kommandozahlen-Tools bauen
und es gibt hier diesen Lib-Git.
Da könnte man ja mal ein schickeres Git machen,
weil ich habe zum Beispiel, als Git 2.0 rauskam,
ging ich davon aus, da könnten die ja eigentlich mal sowas machen,
wie die Inconsistencies zwischen...
rauskam. Wann war das denn?
Vor fünf, sechs Jahren. Echt?
So kurz erst? Keine Ahnung.
Krass. Also das
Git 2.0 war nicht wirklich Breaking Changes
in dem
Kommandozeileninterface dabei. Aber
was mich an Git vor 2.0
schon genervt hat und leider nach 2.0 immer noch,
ist, dass du, dass es ja komplett
inkonsistente Kommandos
haben. Ja, genau das.
Du machst erstens, also gab es irgendwie, wie heißt es?
Git
Beans? Nee, nicht Git Beans.
Git-Cones, war das Git-Cones?
Warte mal.
Git-Cones,
war es das?
Aber was mich an Git eigentlich schon immer genervt hat,
ist, du hast ja unterschiedliche Befehle.
Zum Beispiel, du kannst Branches unbenennen,
du kannst Tags unbenennen, du kannst
Remotes unbenennen.
Das heißt mal Strich M für Move,
das heißt mal Rename und das heißt mal
R.
Ja, das ist ziemlich inkonsenswert.
Und das Löschen von Tags, das Löschen von Branches,
das Löschen von Remotes ist
komplett inkonsistent. Und ich dachte mir,
wenn sie G2.0 rausbringen, dann werden sie es bestimmt mal
gleich machen. Das haben sie nie.
Man muss ziemlich viel
Arcane Knowledge im Kopf halten.
Das Problem ist halt, dass Git eigentlich nur dieses Plumbing
unten drunter ist und viele von den Kommandos,
die du hast, die sind ja, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob es vorher schon viele,
ob es vorher schon Tools war, es könnte sein,
dass Git das irgendwie hauptsächlich gebracht hat,
dass du einen Befehl hast, der heißt einfach Git.
Achso, dass du natürlich viele Subcommands hast.
Dass du so Subcommands hast, aber die Subcommands,
Das ist auch bei Cargo.
Du kannst, wenn du eine Binary hast,
die git-strich irgendwas heißt,
dann kannst du die über die git-Binary auch als Subcommand ausführen.
Genau, kannst einfach ein Leerzeichen statt das Strich schreiben.
Genau.
Und bei git waren, glaube ich, einfach viele Sachen,
da waren manche von den Subcommands,
das war ein Bash geschrieben, manche war ein Perl geschrieben.
Hat so ein bisschen so eine Microservice-Denkweise mit drin.
So eine Microservice-CI-Geschichte quasi.
Deswegen ist es aber auch einigermaßen inkonsistent.
Da denkt sich einer, Git kann man,
das macht ja bloß das Plumbing, da kann ich oben drauf
ein schickes neues Git-Tool bauen, das verhält sich
jetzt anders und dann hast du,
aber wir nehmen es jetzt alles einfach als Sub-Kommandos
von dem eigentlichen Git wahr, deswegen ist es
historisch inkonsistent.
An und für sich, was war damals
das Gegendings von
hier, HG Mercurial?
Das ist an und für sich wesentlich konsistenter, weil das
aus einem Guss ist.
Da ist das
eigentliche VCS und die Kommandozeite,
die UX, ist 1.
Bei Git ist das eher so ein Konglomerat von Sachen.
Das ist alles mittlerweile die gleiche Distribution,
aber es kommt irgendwie alles aus unterschiedlichen Schulen.
Ich kenne es jetzt bei Swift zum Beispiel,
da ist es genauso.
Der ist vielleicht Compiler,
beziehungsweise die ganzen einzelnen Tools,
die man denkt, was unsere Befehle sind,
einfach von Packet Managers und so weiter,
das sind auch eigene Binarys.
Aber die kommen trotzdem in dem Sinne mit aus einem Guss,
dass die aus dem selben Projekt gebaut werden,
die selben dependencies benutzen und so weiter.
Ich frage mich, was ist denn der Vorteil daran,
wenn man das so aufsplittet, wie mit gibt es
in Auffallspart. Aber du kannst ohne weiteres Third-Party-Sachen
mit hinzufügen. Ja, aber das kannst du doch
so auch auf dieselbe Art und Weise.
Du kannst einzelne Binaries schneller
bauen, weil du
Du bist flexibler
potenziell im Austauschen von Sachen, aber es können halt
auch einzelne Sachen kaputt gehen und du merkst es halt nicht mal.
Also bei Cargo ist es so, dass du immer
die meiste Logik hast in dieser
Cargo-Library und die musst du halt an jeder dieser
Untersachen mit rankompilieren.
Also hast du da eigentlich nicht sonderlich viel gewonnen.
Bei Git hast du wenigstens so ein Git-Underkommando,
so ein Git-Checkout oder so ein Git-Squash oder was es gibt.
Das ruft einfach Befehle auf dem eigentlichen Git-Kommando auf.
Da hast du eigentlich was gespart.
Sonst ist das ein Vorteil.
Vornehmlich würde ich sagen,
dass du neue Third-Party-Sachen auch ganz gut unterstützt.
Es gibt ja sowas wie Git-Extras.
Oder für Cargo gibt es halt ganz viele Extra-Kommandos auf Craze.io,
die einfach Cargo-irgendwas sind.
Witzig, dass die auch mal Plugins heißen, das finde ich mal schön.
Das sind eigentlich keine Plugins, ne?
Weil ich glaube, Cargo selber würde die nicht discoveren.
Wenn ich jetzt Cargo Help mache und mir alle Subcommands aufzeigen lasse,
dann zeigt er mir nur die, die eingebaut sind.
Obwohl man das sogar noch wahrscheinlich erweitern könnte,
dass es die eben mit discovered, aber es sind halt trotzdem keine Plugins.
Das sind halt einfach extra Executables,
die einfach aufgrund von Shell Magic sich aufrufen wie Cargo Subcommands.
Genau.
Auch wenn die auf Cargo meinetwegen sogar zurückgreifen,
teilweise für ihre Funktionalität und meinetwegen sogar Cargo aufrufen.
Ich meine, ich habe auch so ein ähnliches Tool gebaut, wo du irgendwie auf einem ASCII-Kommando unterschiedliche SAP-Kommandos aufrufen kannst. Würde es Sinn machen, wenn ich das jetzt aufspalte in einzelne Binarys?
Wenn man festgestellt ist, dass es das nicht unbedingt einfacher macht, weil sie alle irgendwie auf die gleiche Grundfunktionalität zugreifen. Es sei denn, du hast wirklich, du möchtest, es sei denn, du möchtest irgendwie nicht, das kann ich mir vorstellen, du möchtest nicht unbedingt, du hast halt deine Git Haupt-Binary, wo die gesamte eigentliche Logik drin ist und du möchtest die nicht dran linken müssen oder sowas, sondern die ist einfach da und das andere sind einfach Shell-Skripte, deswegen gab es plötzlich Shell-Skripte.
Skripte und das Git,
diese Shell-Skripte, diese Git-Strich-Geschichten
aufruft, das ist glaube ich auch erst später gekommen.
Also du hast am Anfang ein bisschen
Checkout schicken, tippen.
Der andere Aspekt ist wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
diese klassische Unix-Philosophie von wegen
do one thing well und nur das.
Genau, was ja auch gut ist eigentlich.
Also nicht ein eindettiges CLI,
die sich um alles kümmert.
Ja, wenn man das ja gut abstrichern kann.
Auf der anderen Seite freue ich mich auch manchmal,
wenn Sachen einfach mit anderen Sachen
dazukommen. Also do one thing well
führt ja dazu,
dass du irgendwie
für jeden Scheiß ein extra Tool brauchst.
Was irgendwie
bei einem C-Compiler, oder wenn du
C programmierst oder C++ programmierst,
da brauchst du ein Tool,
da brauchst du ein Build-Tool, da brauchst du einen Compiler, dann hast du
ein Tool, was dein Debugger ist, dann hast du
ein Tool, da hast du ein,
sowas wie Package Manager gab es erst irgendwie, später sind
nochmal andere Tools, das ist alles nicht drin.
Der Gegenentwurf ist jetzt die neueste
Runtime oder Programmiersprache, die mir
so einfällt, ist zum Beispiel Dino oder
Go oder Swift.
Bei Dino finde ich es ganz krass,
das macht halt das, was Node macht,
aber du sagst halt Dino für alles.
Du sagst Dino für Test, du sagst Dino
und das ist einfach eingebaut, was du normalerweise über
NPM kriegen würdest oder Jan.
Du sagst einfach Dino Test, Dino Run,
Dino Build, Dino Format,
Dino Install, Dino
Package, Dino und das
kommt alles aus dem Ding raus.
Versuch mal eine von diesen Komponenten da auszutauschen,
mal was anderes zu verwenden, dann fängst du
wieder an, externe Sachen zu bauen.
wahrscheinlich auch genau einfach dem geschuldet, dass
die Dino-Entwickler wissen,
das System kennen, das Ecosystem
und wissen, was halt gewollt wird.
Das ist der Segen der späten Geburt.
Das ist ein schöner Begriff.
Ja, das ist sehr treffend auf jeden Fall.
Man weiß einfach, wenn man mittlerweile
eine neue Programmiersprache rausbringt, dann
wollen Leute sowas haben wie
einen Run-Befehl
oder einen Debug-Befehl oder
einen Package oder einen Format.
Also gerade das mit dem Format-Thing ist ja auch aus den letzten
Jahren so richtig, dass du alles
gittieren musst. Das ist ja auch
quasi was, ach, lassen Sie sich über Formatting reden,
aber ich weiß wiederum. Das ist ein ganz schönes
Thema, aber ja. Aber Git-Cons
hier, hast du es dir mal gemacht?
Ich erinnere mich auch vage dran an diese Seite,
dass du halt die
Inkonsistenz
schön aufzeigst
in so einem herrlichen Text.
So, vielleicht können wir das mal
lesen. A Python-Programmer handed her
.git-config to the Git-Master.
Among the many lines were
the following. Alias
explicit is better than implicit.
If we want to merge,
we should do so
ourselves.
Als Kommentar.
Pull equals pull dash dash
ff dash only.
Also das ist pull alias.
Du bist jetzt git master?
Achso, ich bin ja master git hier.
Master git nodded.
Git pull origin master, said the program.
Achso, nee, warte, ich habe nur gewusst.
Wir sind nicht sehr gut im Storyful.
Master git nodded.
Git pull origin master, said the programmer.
Master git pulled down the latest changes on master and automatically merged them with the programmer's changes.
But master git, did I not say to only fast forward in my configuration, she cried.
Master git looked at her, nodded, and said nothing.
Then why did you not warn me of the problem with my configuration, she asked.
Master git replied, there was no problem.
Months later, the programmer was reading
git dash dash help config
for a different reason and found enlightenment.
I did find four different reasons.
The one thing.
Das ist, glaube ich, hier das Schöne.
Also, a Unix programmer
Unix programmer was working in the cubicle farms.
Oh, scheiße.
As she saw Master Git traveling down the path,
she ran to meet him.
It is an honor to meet you, Master Git.
Wir sollten uns mal über dieses Master noch mal unterhalten.
It's an honor to meet you, Master Git, she said.
I have been studying the Unix way of designing programs that each do one thing well.
Surely I can learn much from you.
Surely, replied Master Git.
How do I change it to a different branch? asked the programmer.
Use git checkout.
How do I change...
How should I create a branch?
Use git checkout.
How should I update the content of a single file in my working directory
without involving branches at all?
Use git checkout.
After the third answer, the programmer was enlightened.
One thing was.
Ah ja, jetzt packen es mal in die Show.
Das ist schön zu lösen.
Aber ich habe dieses Git Oxide ausprobiert.
Das kann eigentlich noch nichts, außer neue Repos anlegen.
Das reicht doch.
Genau, und da sagst du halt
Gigs, ich glaub Gigs.
Gigs, ja.
Gigs in it.
Und es erzeugt dir ein neues Repo mit einem Main-Branch.
Toll, yay, find ich toll.
Hast du schon Sachen von Master
auf Main umbenannt?
Ja, ich mach das eigentlich in jedem Repo, das ich jetzt anfasse.
Ich hab das nämlich auch
nur bei den Notification-Dings jetzt gemacht.
Das sind ein paar Handgriffe und es hat eine
Weile GitHub nicht wirklich
gefressen, dass ich jetzt bitte nicht mehr auf
Master, sondern auf Main arbeiten möchte.
Aber gerade GitHub macht das eigentlich super easy.
Du musst doch bloß den Branch, lokal
branchen, pushen und den Default
geändert. Ja, genau. Irgendwie hat es bei mir beim Pushen
erst nach dem dritten Mal funktioniert, aber vielleicht hatte ich
da auch einfach Pech an dem Tag.
So,
naja. Nee, aber ansonsten habe ich
das nicht übergemacht. Xcode hat interessanterweise
auch den Default geändert, fand ich ganz cool.
Das war ja irgendwie relativ kurz darauf, dass die
die Einstellung geändert haben.
Genau, das ist halt so ein einfacher kleiner Change,
warum nicht einfach machen. Ich glaube, bei Cargo
ist es noch nicht so. Das legt ja
irgendwie auch ein neues Repo an.
weiß ich gerade nicht, ob das der Default ist,
dass die Main oder
Master benutzen. Sie haben überhaupt,
ach nee, warte, genau, als ich auf Twitter gelesen
habe, dass Xcode jetzt neue Repos mit
Main anlegt, habe ich geguckt,
wie sieht denn das bei Cargo aus? Machen die
vielleicht demnächst auch so eine Änderung?
Und dann habe ich überhaupt erstmal gesehen, dass dann ein Pull Request
weitergetrieben wurde, wo drin stand,
oben drüber so als Überschrift,
make it more easy to use other main branches
other than master.
Hat der Cargo noch extra Tooling gehabt, was diesen Namen
erwartet hat? Naja, es ist einfach irgendwo, es ist
hart eingebaut und da
muss jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
Änderungen gemacht werden, dass du überhaupt angeben kannst,
dass dein Hauptbranch
nicht Master heißen soll.
Das wird vielleicht irgendwie in der nächsten oder übernächsten
Version landen, keine Ahnung.
Normalfall ist das ja auch kein großes Problem bei
manchen Projekten, also wenn du den Branch umbenennen möchtest
bei was, was du schon länger hast, kannst
halt ein bisschen mehr Arbeit machen, je nachdem wie viel Zuling
er noch aufbaut, ob da irgendwelche CI-Pipelines sind
oder irgendwas weiteres. CI-Pipelines sind
manchmal das Schlimmste dann eher. Wenn du irgendwie fünf Sachen hast,
auf Master wieder zurückpushen. Ja genau, vor allem
wenn die halt zurückpushen noch und dann ist das irgendwie noch
über drei verschiedene Jenkins-Jobs
oder Files geteilt und dann
so viel Magic, die du gar nicht mehr
nachvollziehen kannst. Und dann ist das ja, weil
das ein Jenkins ist. Ich rede hier auch von spaßigen
Projekten auf Arbeit. Alles doch in Google
geschrieben. Ich habe gestern bis
halb neun auf Jenkins-Sachen rumgeschraubt,
weil es bei uns hieß, ja, wir
schalten diese Docker-Agents
ab. Wir nehmen jetzt nur noch diese Docker-Agents.
Migriert mal bitte alles. Ach übrigens, da geht
das und das jetzt auch nicht mehr. Credentials werden
diese Art und Weise gehandelt, baut mal bitte alles um.
Und wir so,
wir haben in dem Hauptprojekt, auf dem ich arbeite, haben wir irgendwie
sechs Jenkins-Files, die unterschiedliche
Sachen machen.
So ein Ding, was einfach CI auslaufen lässt,
ein Ding, was irgendwie so ein Nack-Bot ist.
Das läuft einfach los,
sind da jetzt die richtigen Approvals auf der
Appurequests, sind da, und das sind halt Sachen,
die mit APIs sprechen, von Bitbucket wieder
und dann irgendwo Credentials herbekommen, die vorher
aus irgendeinem Grund in den Docker-Files drin waren
und jetzt von woanders geholfen werden mussten.
Da sind also Sachen gemacht worden, da wusste sie gar nicht,
Brauchen die jetzt Credentials oder nicht? Es ging einfach.
Ach, es war schön.
Die Hauptarbeit habe ich gar nicht selber gemacht.
Gestern Abend musste ich bloß noch eine Weile mit dabei sitzen
bei einem Projekt.
Dann startest du eine Viertelstunde.
Dann startest du noch eine Viertelstunde.
Du wartest ja, dass irgendwie der Bild bis zu einem gewissen Punkt kommt.
Bis überhaupt das Ding eintritt.
Du kannst Jenkins nicht lokal testen.
Don't get me started.
Da habe ich letztens noch was Cooles gefunden.
Kennst du auch eine Möglichkeit, Jenkins-Files lokal zu validieren?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, nicht in Bezug auf Jenkins,
aber für GitHub-Actions
hat mir der,
ich habe das gerade von Vincent,
ein Tool gezeigt, was genau das macht,
dass du halt eine GitHub-Action, genau,
Act heißt das, run your GitHub-Actions locally.
Gut. Weil es halt immer genau derselbe Kram ist,
dass du gerade die CI-Pipeline,
halt, wenn du da
Dinge dran änderst, dann hast du halt einen extra Branch
und machst da halt 15 kleine
Commit.
Und am Ende squarst du das alles.
Und das Schöne an GitHub-Actions ist ja, dass die generell über haufenweise Docker-Container einfach laufen und das ganze Zeug halt offen darlegt.
Und deswegen ist, glaube ich, Act auch gar nicht so der große Aufwand gewesen.
Ich will natürlich nicht unterstellen, jetzt checkt schon Arbeit drin.
Aber das auch, dass das auf dieselbe Art und Weise lokal läuft.
Und das finde ich ziemlich cool.
Und dann kannst du den Kram einfach lokal testen, schauen, ob das alles richtig läuft.
Weil er auch dieses von GitHub-spezifische Format nutzt für die Actions.
Also das ist die
Jamel-Dateien da, genau.
Ach ja.
Wenn wir jetzt generell nur noch bei den GitHub-Projekten sind,
wollen wir vielleicht mal zu unseren Stars
übergehen? Ja, lass uns über unsere Sterne reden.
Dann fange ich doch gleich mal an mit was, was überhaupt
nichts mit Git zu tun hat, nämlich mit einem
coolen Projekt namens Git Vanity Hash.
What?
Ich liebe so Sachen,
die so Vanity Hashes erzeugen. Ich habe noch
letztens ja bei diesen
Scams, wo jemand
diesen Twitter-Hack,
wo Leute so Bitcoin-Scams gemacht haben
mit populären Accounts.
Es gab nochmal sowas, wo jemand den SpaceX-YouTube-Account
vor kurzem übernommen hat und da auch so einen Bitcoin-Scam
gemacht hat.
Da hat diese Person eben
quasi Elon Musk vorgetäuscht
mit einer Adresse und ich glaube, die war auch irgendwie
1 Musk oder so die Adresse.
Er hat mich daran erinnert, dass ich auch mal die
Bitcoin-Adresse 1Kilean hatte, sogar mehrere,
die mit 1Kilean gebunden hat.
Ich weiß, dass ich mal irgendeinen Rechner an der Uni ein paar Stunden
gequält haben, um irgendwie eine
H00D1E
Gab's H
überhaupt? Ne, das müsste dann 400
Also anyway, das
Also so, wenn ich die Hashes meine, ist immer so eine
witzige Sache, dass du halt einen bestimmten Präfix hast
und es gibt so ein paar Projekte, die das halt
für Git-Hashes machen, aber die fand ich immer ein bisschen
kacke, weil die halt entweder mit dem
Committernamen gespielt haben und dann auch random
Text angehangen haben, oder was ich noch
nerviger fand, dass die mit dem
Timestamp gespielt haben und den halt
Sekunden, wenn nicht Minuten, wenn nicht Stunden,
wenn nicht Tage in die Vergangenheit geschoben haben.
Das macht der natürlich auch ein bisschen blöd.
Und wie kann man es besser machen?
Und Vanity Hash geht halt, abgehend davon,
dass es natürlich in Rust geschrieben ist und deshalb ein wenig cool ist,
geht halt
noch ein bisschen angenehmer daher
und haut in den Commit Header
einfach noch einen Vanity Header mit rein.
Und da halt einen Random String.
In den Commit Header?
Genau, Commits haben einen Header, wo sie drinstehen.
Der natürlich
beeinflusst ja auch den Hash, das stimmt.
Genau, da steht halt der Parent,
beziehungsweise der Author und der Committer und solche
Informationen mit drin. Und da kann man halt noch einen weiteren
Hälter einfach hinzufügen. Du kannst theoretisch
in einen Git-Commit
den Hash von dem
Commit selber reinschreiben.
Theoretisch?
Weil es ja immer noch
SHA-1 ist, oder? Ja, genau.
Ich meine, das kostet sich trotzdem...
Das kostet schon ein bisschen Zeit, aber...
Easy ist das nicht, aber machbar ist es auf jeden Fall.
Nicht unendlich für auf jeden Fall.
Wäre auf jeden Fall sehr cool.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Gag wert wäre.
Aber mit Vanity Hash
kannst du zumindest so etwas Witziges machen,
was ich jetzt mal gemacht habe in einem anderen Projekt.
Dass einfach jeder Kommit mit einem Präfix seiner Wahl anfängt.
Weil es witzig ist.
Wie lange dauert es, einen Vanity Hader zu kriegen?
Nicht so lange.
Die hängt halt von der Länge ab,
die du haben möchtest für deinen Präfix.
Aber ein paar Buchstaben ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Nice.
Finde ich sehr witzig.
Und eine coole Empfindierung davon.
Okay, ich hab was, das hat nicht wirklich was mit Rastotone
aber ich hab jetzt
doch, ich hab vielleicht schon mal davon erzählt
wie ich es gesehen habe
und es geil fand, aber nicht wusste wie es heißt
und jetzt weiß ich wie es heißt, weil nämlich
ein Kumpel von mir damit gespielt hat
und zwar ist das Sonic Pie, kennst du Sonic Pie?
Ich glaub nicht
Also pass auf, also Sonic Pie, ich schmeiß mir mal
die Seite dazu rein
und aber eigentlich muss man auch das Video
dazu sich angucken und im Endeffekt geht es da
Sonic Pie ist
eine Library, eine Sprache,
eine IDE.
Doch, das ist gut bekannt vor. Genau, und es ist
hier von dem Sam
Aaron selber entwickelt und vorgeführt und der
hatte das, ich glaube, der war das auch, der
beim Oxide,
bei dieser Rust-Konferenz da für die Zwischenmusik
gesorgt hatte. Der hat dann einfach Screensharing angemacht.
Was ist Sonic Pi? Sonic Pi
ist, du hast eine IDE,
da schreibst du Ruby drinnen und
da benutzt du eine Library und
du kannst da Samples beschreiben und Musik
Mitschreiber machen. Du kannst es quasi in eine Live-Coding,
Live-Coding nennt sich das, genau,
Live-Coding-Idi.
Und da kommt ziemlich
geiler Mockeball raus.
Ich würde gerne sagen, ich könnte dir
jetzt hier mal was vorspielen, weil ich es irgendwie
vor zwei, drei Wochen entdeckt habe und damit mal spielen
wollte. Und dann habe ich
zehn Minuten damit gespielt, dann war ich super frustriert,
weil es kein Film-Editor ist.
Nein!
Daran ist es gescheitert.
Ich kann nicht daran arbeiten.
Dann ging es los mit, ah, gibt es da
vielleicht Win-Plugins für das Ding? Ne, gibt's
nicht. Das ist irgendwie eine cute
Anwendung. Achso, das ist wirklich das
volle Environment. Das ist das volle Environment.
Es ist ein Editor mit
Code-Highlighting für das Ruby. Du hast da
an der Seite hast du drinnen, du hast
eine Visualisierung von der MAU-U, du hast irgendwie
Loops und Logs, die da drin laufen. Du hast auch
Tutorials und die Erklärung für die
Standard-Sound-Bibliothek.
Du kannst da Samples mehr machen. Du kannst
einfach bloß Beats machen und irgendwie so
Lo-Fi-Techno draus produzieren oder
Minimal. Oder du kannst, das hat
Kumpel von mir gemacht, der hat richtig, du kannst einfach
die Frequenzen dann geben und Noten schreiben, der hat einfach
irgendwelche Musik transkribiert und hat wirklich
Noten abgeschrieben und Musik gemacht.
Ich würde jetzt hier gerne was spielen, aber ich habe tatsächlich
nicht wirklich was Gutes vorbereitet, aber
schaut euch das mal an und wenn irgendjemand damit schon
Erfahrung hat, dann kann er damit gerne
mal auf mich zukommen. Und was ich gefunden habe,
ist, ich habe geguckt, gibt es da vielleicht Wim-Plugins
für? Also wie gesagt, für die IDE selber nicht,
aber du kannst es irgendwie remoten
und dann kannst du nebenbei ein Wim aufhaben
und hast ein Wim-Plugin, was dann mit diesem Ding spricht.
Und das Ding heißt
Sonic Pi Tool.
Und das ist in Rust geschrieben.
Dann passt es gut in unsere Kategorie
Rust-Projekt der Woche hier mit rein.
Schmeiß mal einfach das hier rein
in unserer Liste.
Das ist eigentlich auch eine verpasste Chance,
da irgendwie einen Sonic-Screwdriver-Witz draus zu machen, oder?
Sonic Tool.
Vielleicht hattest du das sogar als Symbol.
It does everything but wood.
Was hast du denn noch so? Ich hatte mal einen Sonic Screwdriver.
Ich hätte sogar mehrere Sonic Screwdriver von verschiedenen
Doktor.
Naja.
Ein anderes RAS-Projekt, das ich mir ausgesucht habe.
Ich will jetzt an dieser Stelle nicht
gestehen müssen, dass ich es Dr. Who nie gesehen
habe. Aber ich weiß grob, das ist was mit
Dr. Who zu tun. Ja, das ist definitiv
Dr. Who.
Ein anderes RAS-Projekt, das ich mir
ausgesucht habe, ist ein Projekt namens
Ruffle. Das ist wirklich immer Zufall.
Das ist wirklich nicht geplant gewesen, aber
sehr witzig gerade.
und Ruffle ist ein Flash-Emulator,
was
ziemlich fancy ist.
Das ist aber schon der fünfte, von dem ich höre.
Ja, aber das läuft halt mega gut.
Interessanterweise sogar prima auf Mobile Safari
auf dem iPhone bei mir. Nice.
Und das ist halt auch krass, um die ganzen coolen Flash-
Spiele und Inhalte von früher eben
zu archivieren. Das ist auch cool, dass Newgrounds
direkt ein Sponsor mit davon ist. Natürlich, die müssen
irgendwie ihr Business-Modell im Leben
halten. Das finde ich großartig.
Das ist so wie Blockbuster, die dir einen VHS-Player
Nein.
Das Einzige Blöde daran ist, ich weiß nicht, was es genau an Safari auf meiner Big Sur Beta Safari ist.
Aber wenn ich die Demos versuche, auf Big Sur Safari zu starten, dann stürzt mein ganzer Backup.
Und läuft das dann im Browser oder läuft das als Standalone?
Das läuft im Browser, weil ich das verstanden habe.
Also ich dachte, das geht direkt auf Wasm rüber, aber ich bin mir gar nicht mal so sicher.
Also ich schätze was von Emulator. Ich habe ja schon von
Projekten gehört, die Flash
transpilieren dann nach Native
Web, JavaScript und Browser
APIs oder sowas. Aber okay,
das ist wahrscheinlich hier pragmatischer.
Cool, das heißt, die haben eine
Action-Script,
einen Action-Script-Interpreter da drin,
oder wie? Kannst du mir auf Ruffle.rs
gehen und die Demos mal anschauen?
Webseite.
So, Demo.
Stört sich jetzt auch meinen ganzen Rechner ab, dann wäre nämlich die
Aufnahme vorbei. Oh, das ist nicht so
vielleicht.
Okay, jetzt muss ich aber hören, wie hier was
Saturday Morning Watchmen. Kennst du auch so was
wie Joe Cartoon? Hast du das mal ausprobiert?
Kennst du Joe Cartoon?
Das kennt natürlich alles nicht mehr.
Der hat also ganz fiese interaktive Comics gemacht.
Mega.
Cool.
Das hat auch schon diese Flash-Optik.
Oh, herrlich.
Was machen wir?
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt nicht machen.
Was machen denn jetzt diese ganzen Filmstudios,
die früher mit Flash auch Filme
gemacht haben? Es gab Filmstudios,
die mit Flash... So was wie Happy Tree Friends
ist doch, glaube ich, mit Flash alles gemacht worden.
Davon habe ich ewig nicht mehr was mit
gehört. Die machen das wahrscheinlich jetzt einfach mit
After Effects oder anderen Tools.
Gibt es ja auch mit Blender
oder... Gibt es das überhaupt noch? Happy Tree
Friends?
Keine Ahnung. Das ist ja ewig hier.
Ach komm, jetzt tu nicht so.
Das war nach Schulzeit, aber das ist ja
schon
eine Weile.
Cool. Nice.
Habe ich irgendwas noch?
Ich hätte sonst...
Ich hätte jetzt hier noch
auf RD oder
RR wäre ich noch mal eingegangen, aber ich kann
es ehrlich gesagt nicht so wirklich erklären, was es ist.
RR ist ein cooler Name.
RR ist ein
Reverse Debugger.
Also ein Bagger.
Genau, es ist ein Bagger.
Nee, es ist eigentlich ein richtig rum-Debugger.
Also ich kann es ja mal
grob anschneiden. Es gibt es RR Projects
übrigens von Marzella.
Und jetzt gibt es RD,
was nochmal ein Rewrite davon ist, in Rust.
Dadurch bin ich
darauf aufmerksam geworden. Aber ich kann dir mal ganz grob erzählen,
was es ist, weil ich es spannend fand.
Und vielleicht braucht es tatsächlich manchmal jemand.
Es ist ein Debugger.
Aber bei einem
B-Wagger bist du ja normalerweise, da attach du irgendwie
einen Debugger an dein Tool
und dann kannst du entweder sagen, ich steppe jetzt
durch mein Tool durch bis zu einem Breakpoint
oder
bis zu meinem Bug
oder ich attache einen Breakpoint irgendwo
und dann hält er automatisch dort an
und dann kann ich, wenn ich dort angehalten bin oder wenn ich
einen Core-Dump habe von der Stelle, wo er dort
rausgeflogen ist, kann ich irgendwie rückwärts
mit dem Stack-Trace angucken.
Das ist halt rückwärts.
RR geht vorwärts und zeichnet
den Ablauf von dem Programm, von dem Start an
bis zu einem Breakpoint oder bis zu einem Crash.
Und dann kannst du das Programm von vorne
abspielen und sagen, ich gehe jetzt mal
durch das Programm, durch was hat das gemacht, bis es dann
an diesem Punkt angekommen ist. Es zeichnet dann relativ
viele Daten auf.
Das sind ja wie diese Elm-Demos,
wo du quasi Time-Travel
während der Execution kannst.
Das kannst du bei Redux-Anwendungen super machen.
Wenn eine Redux-Anwendung
basiert, ändert ihr den State immer nur aufgrund
von Messages.
Debugger sind eigentlich ziemlich geil. Und dann kannst du sagen,
cool, ich spiele jetzt einfach alle Messages von vorne
nochmal ab und dann siehst du halt wieder in der App sich da rein
und kannst du so vor- und zurückspulen
in der State-Geschichte deiner Anwendung.
Das ist schön, wenn du den State so beeinflussen kannst
auf die Art und Weise, weil es halt
alles nur eine Funktion des States ist.
Hattet ihr nicht in Hello Swift
von sowas neulich mal geredet?
Dass du irgendwie so eine Art Redux,
bei irgendwas habe ich mir noch nicht gedacht, ach, das klingt wie Redux,
bloß halt wie Swift.
In der Combine-Folge vielleicht.
Ja, genau, wahrscheinlich.
Das klang auch, als wäre es einfach so eine Art Vitax gewesen.
So, das ist jetzt sehr viel einfach bloß so
Gelaber gewesen, was wir jetzt gerade
machen. Müssen wir
wieder einen Podcast mit
einem Gast machen oder mit einem wichtigen Thema
oder mit sowas.
Wollte ich mal eine Sprachenfolge machen, explizit, so eine
ESOLANG-Folge? Stimmt, wir wollten
mal so eine ESOLANG-Folge machen. Da finden wir
bestimmt jemanden, der Lust hat, mit uns
bei ESOLANGs zu sprechen.
Hallo, liebe Zuhörer. Wenn du Lust hast,
akonomisierbar, zu Gast zu sein.
Kennen wir irgendwelche
ESO-Lang-Expertinnen, die ja irgendwie,
mir fällt niemand ein.
Aber ja, unseren Hörern gibt es bestimmt
irgendwelche Interessenten dafür.
Also wenn ihr Lust habt, über uns mit
über ESO-Sprachen zu klabern und die mal
anzuschauen. ESO-Sprachen sind ja
generell toll.
Aber bei ESO-Sprachen, du hast
ja mal ein Foto auch drüber gemacht, aber
wie viel Zeit kann man
wirklich mit einer ESO-Sprache verbringen,
außer dass man es...
Also Zeit verbringen schon.
Wenn du versuchst,
wenn du jetzt wirklich mit ESO-Sprachen arbeiten,
die nicht komplette Autisten sind oder so.
Ich meine, du kannst schon mit ESO-Sprachen arbeiten,
aber der ganze Sinn der ESO-Sprache ist ja,
mehr Kunst zu sein.
Ob das jetzt irgendeinen Mehrwert hat,
wenn du auch nur schaffst,
irgendwas Funktionierendes in Melbourne zu schreiben,
glaube ich eher nicht.
Ach so, was ich erwähnen könnte,
was keine ISO-Sprache ist, aber es gibt ja diese
Kennst du Bucklescript?
Nee.
Ich hab vielleicht schon mal über Reason geredet.
Ja.
Reason ist
eine etliche Folgen her.
Es ist eine etliche Folgen her, aber ich hab mal auch
einen Moment überlegt, vielleicht ist das schicker als TypeScript.
Reason ist
einfach OCaml.
Bloß in einer anderen Syntax, die konventioneller ist
und dementsprechend lesbarer.
OCaml ist eigentlich eine schöne Sprache. Du guckst dir an,
was OCaml macht und dann denkst du so, ach ja, das liebe ich
und das liebe ich an Rust und das liebe ich an Rust.
Und dann stellst du fest, fuck Rust ist einfach bloß ein OCaml.
Dann schaffst du die Syntax von OCaml
und dann so, what? Und dann guckst du dir die Syntax
von dem Ding an und denkst dir so, sag mal,
was habt ihr geraucht?
Und Reason ist quasi einfach
bloß ein Reasonable OCaml.
Ja, schön.
Und das basiert aber eigentlich
auf Buckel-Script. Was ist Buckel-Script?
Buckel-Script ist OCaml für einen Webbrowser.
Also es ist, nimm OCaml,
nimm OCaml, gib dem irgendwie
noch eine Zusatz-JS-Library.
du hast Sachen, die du mit JS. zugreifst,
dann hast du JS.console und kannst aus OCaml raus
auf der JavaScript-Konsole schreiben.
Und dann nimmst du dein OCaml und schreibst dafür für den Webbrowser.
Und wahrscheinlich, weil das auch keiner machen wollte,
haben sie Reason erfunden.
Damit schreibst du quasi erst,
kompiliert von Reason nach OCaml
und dann von OCaml nach JavaScript.
Und dieses Buckel-Skript hat sich jetzt umbenannt.
Das heißt jetzt nicht mehr Buckel-Skript,
sondern das heißt jetzt Rescript.
das hießen nämlich vorher, Buckel-Skript-Dateien
hießen.bs
und so heißen sie jetzt nicht mehr.
Die heißen jetzt auch.
Aber ist es natürlich auch.rs und voll verwirrend?
Reason-Dateien
heißen.re.
Deswegen hat Reason auch diesen
hat auch dieses schöne
Karo-Logo mit dem re,
was genauso aussieht wie das TypeScript-Logo oder das
JavaScript-Logo, wo einfach die beiden Buchstaben
von der Dateiennung drinstehen.
Das ist cool.
Ja, genau. Also Reason ist eigentlich eine super
schicke Sache. Ich glaube, ich habe mich damit
hauptsächlich dagegen entschieden, weil
du beim Debuggen dann
wieder eine andere Sprache lesen musst. Also klar,
du kannst auch wahrscheinlich Source Maps
und sowas anwenden, aber es kommt wirklich halt
transpiliert was sehr anderes bei raus.
Bei TypeScript hast du schon
TypeScript und JavaScript sind immer die gleiche
Sprache, bloß einmal mit Type-Annotation
und einmal nicht.
Obwohl ich schon gerne manchmal irgendwie
dann Matching und richtige Algebra
Datentypen und sowas in
TypeScript hätte.
Ja, es gibt immer andere Features in anderen
Sprachen, die jemand gerne hätte.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt in letzter Zeit wesentlich mehr so
TypeScript Metaprogramming
gemacht, was sehr viel Spaß gemacht hat.
Es ist irgendwie schwer, ich habe neulich versucht, das
jemandem verbal wiederzugeben. Es ist irgendwie schwer, das zu
verkaufen, aber du kannst irgendwie
kannst schon irgendwie geiler
abgeleitete so Mapped Types
in TypeScript beschreiben, die
wo ich eigentlich von keiner anderen Sprache weiß, wie das gehen würde.
Ja.
Aber wie beschreibe ich es?
In TypeScript, kannst du mir mal sagen, ob du eine andere Sprache kennst,
die das kann? In TypeScript kriegst du
Typen, so generische Typen,
wo du dann ein Interface reinsteckst
und damit hast du dann eine abgeleitete Version von dem
Interface.
Also, es gibt in der Standardbibliothek
gibt es einen Typ, der heißt
Read-Only. Du kannst dir einmal
ein Interface in TypeScript ist wie ein Struct,
du hast irgendwie deine Key-Value-Paare
und du hast Modifikatoren, du hast da Sachen,
du kannst da Sachen reinschreiben wie
Read-Only oder Optional mit Fragezeichen.
So, und dann kannst du,
wenn du ein Interface hast, wo
Name, Nachname, Alter drinstehen,
alles Required, kannst du ein
Partial-Person-Interface
machen und dann nimmt es quasi
das gesamte Ding, aber macht aus jedem Property
ein Optional. Okay.
Du kannst auch ein Required machen,
da geht es drüber und macht aus jedem
wieder nicht optional.
Das kannst du, oder du kannst
das gleiche mit Read-Only machen, dann machst du aus jedem ein Read-Only.
Du kannst Typen
in TypeScript anwenden, wo du sagst,
dieser Typ ist ein Union von
allen möglichen Keys aus diesem Interface.
Okay. Und damit kannst du eigentlich
super coole Sachen machen. Also ich hab, ich hab jetzt
so Sachen, ich wollte ein Protokoll
beschreiben.
Das ist jetzt übrigens eine Tension, aber ich find's geil.
Na dann.
Du machst ein Interface,
ich fand so Sachen schön,
die ich in Rust gemacht habe, wo du sagst,
mein Protokoll ist dieser Typ.
Jede Nachricht, die in diesem
Protokoll gesprochen wird, ist genau dieser Typ.
Das ist in Rust, geht das bei einem Inam und dann
kannst du es serialisieren und wenn du es serialisierst,
wird da mit Ser, da wird da irgendwie ein Tag herangeschrieben,
welcher Fall von dem Inam das ist.
In TypeScript kannst du was ähnliches machen, du musst bloß die Tags selber
schreiben. Du schreibst also quasi lauter
Interfaces, du hast eine Nachricht, die heißt Connect, du hast eine Nachricht,
die heißt Disconnect, du hast eine Nachricht, die heißt
SendChatMessage oder Mute oder sowas
und dann, die müssen einfach immer die gleiche
Struktur haben.
und zwar in Kind oder
Type oder Tag, was da drin steht
und dann gibt es in TypeScript Literal
Types, das heißt, du hast ein Interface,
das beschreibt, ich bin
dieses Objekt und an der Stelle
Tag oder Kind steht ein String, aber nicht
irgendein String, sondern dieser String.
Und dann kannst du zwei Objekte haben.
Ist das nachvollziehbar? Ich glaube schon, ja.
Du kannst zwei Objekte haben, die haben beide in Kind.
Das ist auch bei beiden ein String,
aber bei dem einen steht Welcome, bei dem anderen
steht Disconnect drin und dann kann der TypeScript
Compiler sagen, oder du kannst dem TypeScript Compiler
so einen Typeguard definieren mit einem
If und dann kannst du sagen,
wenn ich in dem If drin bin und
gecheckt habe, dass mein Kind,
dass da Welcome drin steht, dann weiß ich
das innerhalb von dem If, dass ich da wirklich
dieses Objekt vom Interface Welcome in der Hand
habe. Ah, witzig.
Also es ist wirklich schön, dass die
TypeScript Entwickler sich sehr viel
Magic ausgedacht haben, um
möglichst viel Typ-Informationen
auf JavaScript draufzulegen. Genau.
Das ist ja auch der ganze Sinn der Sprache.
Und was ich jetzt in Type-Spring-Bahn zum Spaß gemacht habe,
was du machen kannst, ist, du kannst jetzt unterschiedliche Messages definieren.
Die haben alle irgendwie einen unterschiedlichen Payload,
aber haben alle einen Payload und einen Type.
Und in dem Type steht bei jedem ein exklusiv eigener String drin.
Und jetzt erzeugst du einen Typ, der heißt Protokollnachricht.
Und das ist einfach die mit Union, also mit so einem Pipe getrenntes Oder,
ist das oder das oder das oder das oder das.
Okay.
Und dann kannst du mit einem Switch sagen,
wenn type gleich welcome oder disconnect, dann.
Und dann sagt dir der Compiler sogar schon,
ah ja, das muss ja dieses Subinterface sein.
Das ist schon mal geil.
Aber was du jetzt machen kannst bei Tabscript,
ist, dass du hingehen kannst und sagen kannst,
von meiner Protokollnachricht,
gib mir mal einen Typen, der alle keins daraus darstellt.
Das heißt, du hast das nie wirklich selber als Liste geschrieben.
Du hast einfach bloß einzelne Interfaces gebaut.
Du hast einen Typen, der sagt,
ich bin entweder das Interface oder das Interface
oder das Interface und aus diesem Interface
Typen kannst du jetzt einen Typen ableiten,
der
als mögliche Zustände
von dem Wert des Typen hat,
alle diese Strings hat.
Das heißt, wenn ich ein neues
Interface hinzufüge und das an
meinen Protokolltypen hinzufüge, dann ist
dieser abgeleitete Typ von diesem
Protokolltypen, hat automatisch einen weiteren
möglichen Wert dazu bekommen.
Ah, ich habe mich noch nicht verstanden.
Es ist blöd zu beschreiben.
Dann kannst du wieder hingehen
und kannst sagen,
ich kann jetzt
einen Mapped-Type machen, wo ich sage,
die Keys sind diese
Tags und
die Values von diesem Interface,
was ich nie initialisieren werde, weil es ein
Hilfertyp ist, die Values wären dann diese
eigentlichen Nachrichten.
Das heißt, ich habe ein Interface, wo die
Keys, wo im Key
drinsteht, Connect
oder Welcome. Das klingt schon fast wie
nach dem Use von dem Feature, oder?
Und in dem Value von dem Interface
würde dann diese tatsächliche Nachricht
stehen. Das ist stammt, oder?
Ja. So, das ist auch wieder was, was
du nicht benutzt, aber das kannst du dann Schema nennen.
Da weißt du dann also, ich habe einen
Typen, da steht drin
Welcome, Welcome Message.
Connect, Connect Message.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Und das kannst du dann wieder mappen, wo du sagst,
ich habe einen Typen, der ist genauso wie dieses Schema,
Aber die ganzen Values sind nicht der Typ, den der Value hat,
sondern eine Funktion, die diesen Typen annimmt.
Und zack, du hast einfach bloß, was du händisch hinschreibst,
eine Haufen Liste von einzelnen Messages
und einen Typ, der alle diese unterschiedlichen Messages
als Wert annehmen kann, dieses Union.
Und das kannst du reingeben in einen abgeleiteten Typen,
der jetzt sagt, okay, jetzt kannst du einen Händler haben.
Ich glaube, das schneide ich alles raus.
Quatsch, das drin.
Jetzt kannst du einen Typen beschreiben,
wo derjenige, der es implementieren muss,
dann quasi ein Objekt beschreibt,
wo wirklich die Kints drinstehen.
Und hinter jedem Kint ist eine Funktion,
wo du definitiv schon weißt, dass die das annimmt.
Okay, ja, ja, ja.
Das heißt, du hast einen Händler
für alle möglichen Nachrichten geschrieben.
Und jetzt kann ich den implementieren.
Das heißt, ich habe ein Objekt,
das steht,
ich habe jetzt ein Objekt, das heißt MessageHändler.
Und da ist, wenn ich den Typen
hinschreibe, dann sagt er mir, du musst jetzt
implementieren, dass du
Property Welcome hast und das hat eine
Funktion und dann sagt er dir schon, ah ja, okay,
die Funktion nimmt jetzt eine Welcome-Nachricht
an.
Mhm.
Das ist kein guter Podcast.
Das ist echt schwer nachvollziehen.
Nee, ich muss da mal einen Vortrag zu behalten, glaube ich.
Ja, mach das mal.
TypeScript Metaprogramming.
Mach das einfach mal so als Blogpost oder
YouTube-Video zum Teil.
Jetzt habt ihr es auf Arbeit gemacht.
Ist das okay, wenn ich da einen Blogpost drüber mache?
Das kannst du ja wahrscheinlich auf meinem Firmenblog machen.
Das gibt es wahrscheinlich auch.
Es gibt eine schöne...
Pass auf, das mache ich einfach zu meinem Star.
Es gibt von einem Typen,
der fällt mir gerade nämlich ein,
wenn du nach Mapped Types in TypeScript suchst,
dann findest du einen Blogpost von einem Typen.
Marius Schulz.
So, der...
Und das ist mein Pick.
Und ihr könnt jetzt gerne das lesen.
Und dann könnt ihr mir noch mal zuhören.
Und es gibt jetzt einen schönen Blogpost zum Thema
Mapped Types in TypeScript.
Und es gibt auch schon ein Advanced Types Chapter
in dem TypeScript in der offiziellen Dokumentation.
Und es ist einfach krass, was du damit alles ausdrücken kannst.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das in Haskell geht
oder in Rust definitiv
nicht ohne
sehr viel Makro-Handstände,
wo du wirklich
Code pausst und
auf dem Ast
rumreitest und selber Zeugs machst. Das kannst du
in TypeScript relativ cool beschreiben,
einfach so. Wenn mir jemand
eine andere Sprache nennt, die das kann, dann bin ich
sehr frohlich darüber. Ein mächtiges Typsystem ist echt
immer was wert, da kann man richtig coolen Kram machen.
Das Fiese ist, dass das alles keinen Code erzeugt.
Das sagt dir bloß, welchen Code du selber schreiben musst.
Aber ist auch ganz cool. Insofern
beruhigt mich das sehr, weil ich weiß,
egal was ich hier schreibe, kannst irgendwie
in C++ ähnliche Sachen mit
Templates machen. Aber dann kann es
halt auch passieren, dass deine Binary
plötzlich doppelt so groß ist. Du kannst alles irgendwie
in C++ machen, aber schön ist das nie.
Genau, und hier
weißt du zumindest, der Code wird definitiv
nicht generiert. Ich weiß immer noch, welcher
Code ist zur Runtime noch da. Das ist irgendwie das,
was bei TypeScript schön ist.
Bei Rust kann es sein
oder bei Reason kann es sein,
dass du irgendwie Types beschreibst,
die dann hinterher, oder eine generische Funktion machst,
die hinterher dazu führt, dass dein Code fünfmal so groß ist.
Das ist eines von den Problemen von Serde.
Deswegen gibt es so was wie Mini-Serde oder Nano-Serde.
Serde ist eine Library, damit annotierst du deinen Code,
deine Structs, und kannst damit quasi daraus deinen Code generieren
und sagen, ich habe jetzt dafür einen Serialisierer
für generische Formate.
Und damit kann ich meinen Struct nach
JSON serialisieren.
Das Problem ist, dass deine Binarys
relativ groß werden, weil Serda
das halt alles ausrollt.
Es wird dann von irgendeinem LLVM irgendwann wieder
wegkompiliert, weil es nie benutzt wird
oder so.
Aber es macht trotzdem relativ große Binarys
draus. Deswegen gibt es so was wie Mini-Serda,
was dann wieder
auf dynamischen Dispatches basiert und
nicht alle generischen Möglichkeiten
statisch ausrollt, sondern irgendwie dann
Dynamic Traits oder so was verwendet.
Interessant.
Ich habe vorhin,
ich glaube, ich habe mich einfach warm geredet gehabt,
weil ich vorhin dieses Zeugs,
was ich gerade beschrieben habe,
mit einem Kollegen, der aus der C++-Welt kam,
erklärt habe.
Und der wollte so etwas Ähnliches bauen und hat sich gewundert,
warum, wenn er Generics benutzt, der Code nicht funktioniert.
Dann hätte ich gesagt, naja,
in C++ haben Generics den Effekt,
dass dein Code dispatched.
In TypeScript
Hat das keinen Effekt.
Das wird validiert und dann
ist es zur Runtime nicht mehr da.
Das ist
so ein Verständnis, was man
bei TypeScript erstmal aufbauen muss.
Du kannst das zwar hinschreiben, aber es generiert halt keinen
Code für dich.
Schon witzig.
Ja.
Gewittert es jetzt eigentlich?
Es regnet zumindest gut gerade.
Da können wir mal vor der Tür
gehen und uns ein bisschen abkühlen, wenn nicht
vom Blitzer schlagen werden oder so.
haben wir sonst noch was
nö, ich finde ich einen guten Schlussstrich
den wir hier ziehen können
ja
das war gerade noch so ein richtig schöner
unanschaulicher Rant von mir
zum Schluss, aber es hat zumindest mir
Spaß gemacht
wenn sich jemand zum Thema TypeScript
an mich wenden möchte, sagt einfach Bescheid
ich labere gerne mal über das TypeScript
Typ System, das ist eigentlich auch nach
Rostmann der Zweitlieblingssprache mittlerweile
ansonsten
gesund. Auf jeden Fall.
Hört fleißig
Podcasts. Ja, aber mir
klappt das irgendwie nicht so in letzter Zeit. Ich versuche
mehr jetzt mal jeden Tag wieder
ein bisschen spazieren zu gehen, einfach nur damit ich ein bisschen Podcast
hören kann. Die Commute-Time, die halt wegfällt,
zu nutzen, weil meine Podcast-Kieber einfach
mittlerweile wirklich ein Kilometer lang ist.
Und das hilft auch, aber man muss halt
trotzdem... Ich hatte gestern früh eine Besorgung
zu machen im Nachbarort.
Musste ich mit dem Auto
hinfahren. Und als
ich da war, habe ich festgestellt,
wo ist eigentlich mein Portemonnaie?
Dann bin ich wieder zurückgefahren.
Dann bin ich nochmal hingefahren.
Also das war gut für meinen Podcast-Backlog.
Aber nicht gut für meinen
CO2-Footprint.
Gut, das war Akronomisierbar
Folge 43.
43, genau. Das nächste Mal ist eine
Schnappszahl, müssen wir trinken.
Also wie 23, tolle Folge immer wieder.
Das ist meine Lieblingsfolge allgemein.
Ja, definitiv ein Highlight
der Akronomisierbar-Geschichte.
Genauso wie diese Folge, die in einem Donnerschlag endet.
Ich glaube, ich gehe wirklich gleich vor der Tür und lasse mich nass regnen.
Also dann, nächste Folge neuer Podcast-Shop beginnt in
3, 2, 1, Risiko.
Let's get dangerous.
you